foreign
[Music]
we have a big Wesley aka Big flexley
here look at him all right man I got
some questions for you so I've always
wanted to ask you we fresh offered a
Fisher random how do we Castle Dewey
Castle can we Castle in check or or not
what's going on
yeah that's uh
I guess depends on what room but if you
look at the feeding and I gotta feed the
handbook they say your king can't move
if it's attacked okay right okay I just
wanted to be sure I've actually done
that myself you know the board chest
there so a little joke there from the
fish for random favorite openings and
why I guess this E4 E5 Queen H5 stuff
okay all right don't give the secrets
away again Wesley go away come on
pre-game rituals so they sent the music
okay what the genre he usually like
oldies okay all these nice yeah how old
50s 60s yeah like 70s wow 70s nice
that's interesting the carpenter okay
I'm not familiar
BG's okay the BG fifth grade yeah
they're definitely yeah I also like uh
Eminem I think okay
yeah of course yeah I'm from Detroit
right yeah so yeah I definitely love the
lemonade we appreciate you thank you of
course congratulations on all your
success and good luck in the tournament
foreign
[Music]
you know we all have nicknames
Chicago is nicely where I'm born and
raised so that's how I got the name I
guess they call me the muscle I'm the
one with the passion I'm always looking
for a good fight you know evidently
it'll make a difference man that's
Checkmate coming up they don't matter
we're trying to do is to let them know
hey we're playing down here in Houston
Texas and if you come down here help
step in trust me we're going to beat you
you better bring your game
three minutes all right let's do it okay
A little London sister
all right wait oh nice development this
ain't bad he thinking he thinking Queen
D2 okay what is that your move
I mean it's cute you know it's a little
part you got more of them you got more
there it is
they actually played no you played good
though you play much better than I did
than I thought right great game brother
thanks Ethan thank you man
foreign
it's our final day inside the luxurious
one Hotel Toronto but inside the
gameplay Hall there is still some
unfinished business on Sunday the
American Wesley so took the lead seizing
opportunities when given but there are
few to rule out India's nihal sarin and
his ability to come all the way back
it's day two of the title match at the
chess.com Global Championship today we
Crown a champion
yes I was born in Vancouver but as
wonderful as Andrea and Vancouver are
it's pretty tough not to fall in love
with the city of Toronto
natural beauty abounds inside Toronto
and pretty close by
largest city in Canada
[Music]
people here have been playing chess and
clubs in universities and in public
parks for well over a century
and now this wonderful place plays host
to the very first chess.com Global
championship finals
facing elimination for weeks two of the
world's best players are one step away
from completing their quest for the
queen size share of the one million
dollar prize pool Queen H6 oh my gosh
before you're not escaping no you're not
Queen to three it's me oh my God and he
goes up two points and is finally
collaps his hand
live you're in the right place it's time
for the cgc's championship match Toronto
Canada officially has it all
thank you once again botez sisters great
job all week opening the show
speaking of work Wesley so has showed up
early on the job as he prepares to
protect his day one lead in Toronto
meanwhile in Belgrade Serbia Nihao
Sauron is thinking about how he might
steal back this championship title
welcome inside the playing Hall I'm on
Hamilton Danny wrench Anish Geary and
Daniel naroditski with you on this
Championship Monday we'll soon be joined
by Fabiano caruana and Robert Hess to
call our opening game today
we find out who will be the first Global
champion of the chess.com Global
Championship that includes a check for
two hundred thousand dollars fellas what
are you looking forward to most Anish
welcome in I hope this chair is a little
more comfortable than the one we had out
there for you thank you glad to be here
you know I'm as a player I want to see
good chess but as a commentator we need
that comeback we need the nihal comeback
we need to get some blood on the board
let's get it rolling Donna you excited
to see what happens on Monday that's the
last day Danny but let's try to extend
this day for as long as possible as a
commentator I totally second a niche I
want to see blood and I want to see an
Armageddon I love how quickly I'm on uh
and he switches from being player to
commentator he knows we want Armageddon
exactly yeah he's he's filling the shoes
nicely yeah and they're filling Canty's
chair nicely as well yeah Danny I second
of course what the guys are saying there
uh Danny I just want to see more chess
yeah you know as a fan we'll see if
nihal can do it it's going to have to be
early if it's going to happen so all
right here's how we got here so and
sarin won their quarter-final matches on
Thursday then so beat Nakamura and
Sauron took down arpal a niche in the
semis on Saturday yesterday we played
our first four games of the title match
and today we reward a winner
all right that's where we sit let's
start with the leader after he took a
two-point lead at the end of Sunday's
games Wesley so spent a few minutes
talking with Nemo Wesley was clearly
excited but also grateful to be here
very good I mean okay my third term in a
row and the first two went badly for
finally something's going well and I'm
very grateful for that I'm also very
fortunate actually to be here because in
the qualifier when I played Jeffy song I
should have actually lost that match so
like I wasn't playing well uh that time
it was like a month ago but now I'm
playing better so I'm very very glad for
that at some point you get tired of
losing too many games and you want to do
better hopefully that's what's happening
to me right now of course and I wanted
to ask what happened on that game three
King to C1 yeah that's uh insane uh
because basically I'm done exchanging a
pawn before that and the nihal found all
these accurate moves E5 D5 Rook D7 like
he found all computer moves like five
moves in a row and I was reeling at that
point I was also down on time
so that was really a critical moment of
the match because he was like winning I
mean it's not an easy win but it was
definitely winning and if I made one
more mistake then the game would be over
yeah I was just trying to make use of
all the chances that could arise right
try to never give up and you know it's
Blitz Anything Can Happen what's your
approach for tomorrow you are one day
away from winning two hundred thousand
dollars yeah the score one and a half
uh the four uh yeah try to make money
[Laughter]
[Music]
Wesley says it's obvious Wesley has had
a not so obvious path to get here to the
finals barely got by Zhang many remember
that but also was just very impressive
overall since getting here in Toronto
he's only 29 years old maybe he had a
rough year in his eyes but he's doing
well here in Canada all right Guys
Wesley humble as always he knows he has
a lead to protect thankfully we have a
guest here who had a two-game lead that
he almost let slip so if you were giving
Wesley the coaching on protecting a lead
what would you be telling him right now
well you know how it happens a move by
move like you don't win two games right
away you don't lose two games right away
but yeah first you know you can
comfortable position turns a little less
comfortable and yeah you know that's how
it starts that's how it um how it goes
but how are you feeling when Roger
almost staged that comeback
yeah I mean it was slipping away and I
I came into the day with a one point
lead I think it's a little different
when you come into the daily there is a
psychological difference you prepared
for a plus two situation for the
two-point lead up front the entire day
so I was actually looking for a very
tense match I was only up by one point
and I won of course the first game and I
was shocked by that a little bit someone
was like wow okay I'm a plus tuner
looking really good so it was a little
different psychology and I feel Wesley
is really confident right now
but anything can happen that I think if
the you know the price the stakes get
into the Wesley's head perhaps that's uh
that's will be that will be the
beginning you know of the of the poison
how does he how does he avoid the poison
Right Wesley is very good at staying
humble keeping himself the underdog you
expect him to do that again here today
on Monday he's been ridiculously
composed under all circumstances good
positions bad positions winning losing
it just doesn't does not matter he's
been totally impervious but the way he
definitely shouldn't approach this is
the way I approached a paper that was
due in two days and I've got the one day
to just screw around and then I can
start working the next day Wesley's got
two losses before Neil catches up to him
but he shouldn't think of you know the
first losses oh you know it's even if I
lose it's okay right he should just try
to put nehal away right off the right
off the bat yep yeah that's a great
Point Dania and you know what else is
the the case here Danny is that when you
ask that question what does Wesley need
to do it's like nothing different yes
keep doing exactly what you're doing
right now because Wesley so has been
dominant everywhere he's not getting too
low on the clock he's turning bad
positions into maybe draws yeah and he's
turning those likely drawn positions
into wins so keep doing what you're
doing if you're Wesley you honestly
don't don't need to change anything he's
been phenomenal so far if it ain't broke
don't fix it they say well someone else
needs to fix something because nihal
Sauron finds himself in a two-point hole
and is starting with the black pieces
after his games on Sunday nihal sat down
with Mike Klein and was honest about the
situation he finds himself in
[Music]
honestly today Wesley just played
amazing chess I'm just too upset about
the third game which I think I totally
outplayed him but then then he showed
some great defense and of course I
should have just taken the drive then
but I just got too carried away and
like with four seconds of course I
should take a draw it's very basic
mistake and against a player like Wesley
it does not go unpunished so don't just
uh great play by him and I just hope to
put up a good fight tomorrow does it
give you a little bit of uh Solace that
you were better in that game and if you
had converted this would actually be an
equal match right now does that give you
some some hope for tomorrow
um not particularly but I'm just I'm
just happy that sort of like more
ambitious than ever just
I'm going all out not something I
usually do so
just
happy that I'm fighting what would you
put your chances at at let's say getting
to at least an Armageddon tomorrow
objectively it's not very high but I'll
just try to
start from zero and just try to forget
to the end
try to put up my best chest tomorrow
here's the score after four games uh as
well as the games that lie ahead for
nihal to dig himself out of this hole
it's first to four and a half points to
win today's match remember that all
right guys so you heard Nihao
and you heard His Thoughts you've made
comebacks as well I know I teased you
about rajama but you've also been in a
spot where you had to come back so now
speaking at large about me how speaking
at large about comebacks what is nihow's
mindset have to be here to change things
yeah I think with the first game playing
with the black pieces and being two
points down I think Niha will want to
play for a win not burning all the
bridges but burning quite quite a bit of
bridges because you need to win two
games you have two whites you can't
waste any chances and I think as a chess
player you know you don't think of some
Grand strategy you think about he's
going to play 1v4 what's my move right
and I think nihal has to figure out the
approach I think the perk the modern
setup with Jesus worked all right
yesterday for him
it's a bit predictable but on the other
hand yeah perhaps that's where his
thoughts like he will maybe study some
Modern variation some peer some move
order somewhere maybe try to surprise
Wesley A6 yesterday maybe today with C6
you know some something along that along
those lines yeah I mean there's only so
much you can do and another opening that
nehal has played successfully against me
in Blitz is the French with black you
know I know first time anybody's using
that word in the pre-game show uh but
friends with black maybe one E4 with
white so he's got to find that middle
ground approach where he you know you
don't have to play one H4 or do
something ridiculous or extreme but
taking Wesley out of his comfort zone a
little bit doing something a little bit
unexpected and just focusing on the
things that he can control he cannot
control Wesley's level and quality of
play so Wesley plays great you know you
take your hat off but you do what you
can do to put yourself in a position
where maybe you'll get lucky yeah yeah
and nihil needs to keep his objectivity
right it's hard really important that
you don't get to emotional about the
match you're down by two you're not
trying to come out here Danny and just
sack a bunch of pieces right and then
you lose a game suddenly the match
really is over so he has to remember
that he's put Wesley in spots where
a lot of people would actually lose
those games yep Wesley has just defended
really well he's handled those moments
Under Pressure really well but if nihal
keeps putting Wesley in those spots I
mean maybe he's gonna make a mistake and
maybe hell can't make this comeback
without a mistake from Wesley so he's
got to put him sometimes you need a
little bit of luck along the way right
but you got to put pressure first
speaking of pressure you felt the
pressure against Niel you know how you
played him and let me just ask you point
Blake do you think he's capable of this
comeback well certainly and you have to
realize that Niha has been coming back
in this event
um first of all against Sam Sevin yeah
against me twice as well so it's not a
new situation for him two point deficit
is more than usual though so I'm not
sure how that feels but he'll certainly
try
okay well you know I think uh the the it
has to start early right it has to start
earlier Don your thoughts on what he
would need to do to strike game one I
think to put Wesley on his heels Ahmad
mentioned an emphasis on objectivity I
agree and I think he shouldn't
exaggerate the magnitude of this crisis
in his head you actually can make a draw
so so the last thing you want to do is
immediately burn all your Bridges and
lose a game right off the bat he can
make one truck he can even make two
draws so I don't think that he needs to
deviate from his normal style all that
drastically yeah I just think he needs
to make a very calculated choices in the
opening again to put himself in a
position where he can at the very least
you know benefit from a mistake by
Wesley okay that's a great point but
also the openings Danny right we have to
remember like this is where Niha has
been struggling he hasn't really
generated anything with the white pieces
I think with the black pieces he's had
some of his great chances in this match
so keep it spicy with the black pieces
but with white he needs something new so
I'm expecting him to come with something
that we might not have seen before yep
all right well it's going to be awesome
we're going to see what happens let's
set the table for our match today we
played four games yesterday we are set
for four more today but remember it's
first to four and a half points wins and
of course the winner gets two hundred
thousand dollars I love saying that it's
three to one Wesley as you can see
before you and we're gonna get into this
matchup on day two of the title match
guys the Styles we we went we started
naturally on the big picture stuff and
it's gotten more and more specific so
now one more time you mentioned the pure
modern but Aman touched on white what
would you do if you were playing white
as Nihao
yeah I mentioned black because you
started the day with the black pieces so
it's always important with the white
pieces that's a good question uh I
didn't like nihal's attempt to take
Wesley in the main line of the Catalan I
think he's more of a sideline guy at the
moment against me he managed to get
interesting positions with certain
Sidelines he tried the Knight F3 B3
sideline against Wesley in the second
white game I think something in the
middle I mean you probably won that pawn
on D4 you know before you put the pawn
on B3 maybe you don't want that one on
C4 like some London system-ish kind of
thing is what I would expect but Wesley
is very solid very well prepared he has
a narrow preparator which he controls
very well you know when you when you
don't play too many things the things
that you do play you know so it's very
hard
um trying to crack through Wesley's
reporter yeah and it reminds me of when
I was rifling through my backpack after
arriving in Toronto I realized I'd
forgotten part of my computer charger
but you just keep opening the same
Pockets trying to find something that's
kind of what new Hall is going through
in the Berlin he's like can I just maybe
find that one sideline now I would argue
that there actually are more legit
Sidelines within the Berlin and within
the real Lopez then one might realize
you can put the queen on E2 early you
could take the Knight on C6 so I feel
pretty strongly that nihal should at
least try one game with one E4 for and
prepare something relatively fresh
because obviously in Rapid you can't
review all of your files before the game
try to catch Wesley off guard again do
what is within your control okay you
want to do what's within your control
and also what you know you know he's had
some success in this tournament with
that London style of opening and he
doesn't just play the main line of it he
has some Sidelines and I I feel like
that's an area where you can catch
Wesley you know not just the main line
of a popular opening but something uh
you know a bit of a deviation something
where Niha will be comfortable you can
maybe get ahead on the clock and put
some pressure on Wesley what's funny
you're saying maybe give it hand in one
E4 you're saying maybe stick with the
London and find us we've got a couple
games we know about nihalis he said he
doesn't even always bring his computer
to it right he wants to stay fresh in
between the games so maybe he has like
you're both wrong I'm just gonna do
puzzle Rush while get ready for the next
thing so all right well we're going to
see how it plays out on the board today
of course but before we do let's review
our picks from Sunday I'm on we start
with you remind everybody who you had
yeah Danny I had Wesley so in this
matchup and obviously with the lead that
he's got right now I'm feeling good
about my pick I also did have Wesley so
I believe he's going to take the day in
the end
I also had Wesley so I also stick to my
pick I also had Wesley so and while I
want to see a close match I'm also
realistic and I think Wesley's gonna
stick to it and win we don't we don't
just say that because he's behind us
right there he just took his seat on the
stage Hey Wesley we see you I know you
hear us you don't have to pretend you
can't hear us it's okay all right he'll
put his headphones on soon but okay this
has been awesome guys can't wait but
that is it for us we'll see you soon
chat and we'll be here after each and
every game until we Crown a champion for
now let's bring in Fabiano caruana and
Robert Hess to call game five of our
title match
thank you Danny great to have you lead
the show as always for me you played so
many matches in your illustrious history
how have you felt and what have you done
when you're trailing a match well I've
been behind like this but I don't know
if I've ever been able to make a
comeback like this but if anyone can do
it it is nihal
you know he's already done this in this
tournament made big comebacks we'll see
if he can do it again okay well right
now he Trails by two points against
Wesley so it is three to one in Wesley's
favor we will have four games
potentially today if Wesley so does not
lock up the match before then but Bobby
you said if anyone can do it it's nihal
sarin just how does he bounce back from
a setback in day one and get on the
right foot here in day two well I think
he has to make a running start for it he
needs to as a guy said needs to start
playing for win from the very first game
because there's limited time and it's
quite a big deficit to make up it
certainly is because two points a lot
Wesley so has a great opening repertoire
and not many people out there in the
chestnut Community predicted this
matchup and only 26 total brackets had
this matchup and 12 of those 26 had Neil
sarin as the winner
quite a few knee-haw Believers out there
Fabi well I have to say I was one of
them and I still hope that it'll be a
very close match but it's getting harder
and harder right and as you just said
there you are also a nehal storm
believer you chose him to win this match
and you know it's harder and harder to
believe in him but I had Wesley so so
you went with nihal sarin I went with
Wesley so and the chat did not agree
with you they went with me they went
with Wesley show as their Global chess
champion we'll see if that comes to
fruition but we want to remind everybody
of the format you may think three to one
what's going on here Wesley so has in
the bag eight total games Fabi so the
guys they were talking about the
strategy eight games how do you see Niha
playing this
yeah I think the first game the most
important thing will be the openings
because the players had an evenly match
in terms of middle game there have been
some small differences here and there
but the openings have been where the
biggest difference has been and where
nihal has struggled so much so he's had
a knight to prepare to think about
Wesley's opening strategy Wesley's a bit
of a limited player in terms of his
opening repertoire but what he knows he
knows super well so Niha will have to
try to find a way to surprise him okay
and we see the players they're on screen
there but in their head to head matchup
between these two not much over the
board experience but Wesley so the older
player he also won their head to head in
the speeches championship last year well
you know I I noticed that last month
when we were playing in the US
championship and Wesley was also playing
he said I tend to struggle against these
young teenagers and he lost a
Christopher you there but he doesn't
seem to be struggling in this match at
all maybe he's found a way to adjust
well you know he certainly has a nihal
sarin will have to find a way to adjust
for himself because the openings have
not been his friend in this event maybe
he wishes that he could have played an
ice and Fisher random chess because his
middle game prowess has been on full
display and as we get set for game five
here in the title match Wesley so gets
the white pieces Fabi I'm just curious
to see nihal's first move after D4
well we see another modern but the
difference here is that Wesley can
potentially approach this in a different
way maybe not playing E4 and we see he
plays G3 he shows his intention and
we'll see a sort of King's Indian setup
now that's right and Wesley so he's kind
of the king of the draw when he needs
one he's so difficult to beat and look
at this C5 spicing things up early is
nihal sarin trying to open up that
Bishop on G7 you know what I'm thinking
now if Wesley wants to play Super solid
C3 that's a way to do it because D5 you
have some sort of potentially benoni D
takes E5 is some sort of unusual you
know I mean not very unusual but
imbalance Pawn structure and C3 is where
he plays very very solid actually a
little bit annoying potentially for
nihal if he wants to play for a win so
you're speaking Wesley so to everybody
out there you knew what he would play in
Queen A5 we tell newer players not to
bring the queen out too early but Fabi
pinning this Pawn on C3 trying to play C
takes D4 so the pawn can't recapture
niho this looks like prep it looks like
at least he's taking it I mean I can't
imagine how prepped you are for this but
maybe he's just saying even if I don't
know the line well I'm just going to
play quickly and confidently and play
something unusual I'm thinking like the
way to punish this now is to play D5
because the queen doesn't belong on A5
in a boat on any structure it's very
misplaced there the only point to this
is that black wants to play C takes E4
avoiding white recapturing with the pawn
so you avoid a symmetrical part
structure the only point of Queen A5 is
I really want to fight at any cost any
other tournament match situation nihal
would not make this move I don't believe
but just because he really feels I need
to make chances winning chances in this
game and that's the correct thing he's
played an unusual move like Queen A5 I
wonder if we'll see either Knight B to
D2 trying to get another you know
symmetrical safe Pawn structure for
Wesley or maybe he wants to punish nihal
with D5 like he tried to you know punish
Hikaru Nakamura when Hikaru was in a
must win and played a very dubious
opening and something you've said and I
think this is a very good point that
when you need to draw you don't play for
a draw you just need to play your normal
chest play for a win but with this
opening by Wesley C3 and now he's
thinking I feel like Neil should be
happy because he notices that Wesley's
trying to keep things symmetrical keeps
things solid and so with the lead on the
clock and maybe more preparation at home
nihal getting the chances he needs at
least as much as you can say after four
moves yeah at least when you know that
your opponent wants to play very safely
it can be a bit predictable and you can
try to maybe capitalize on that it's not
easy but you can you sense your
opponent's fear in a way maybe it's not
like a very strong fear like Wesley's
not worried in this position that you
know he's worse or anything of course he
knows he's slightly better but it's a
fear of I don't want to get into a sharp
double-edged position because I really
want to wrap this match home and
something Anish said the stakes the huge
prize fund being so close to a huge
Victory like in the chess Global
Championship maybe that'll get into
Wesley's head a little bit that's where
nihal's hope will lie if if there is
hope that's what he should be thinking
you know maybe Wesley will start to get
nervous okay we did just see the move A3
Wesley making his intentions clear with
the move B4 and now black can take on
d458 the point is the C3 Pawn is pinned
the C3 Pawn cannot capture but I think
he'll still play B4 but this is what you
I feel like you want if you're new white
to overextend throw pawns forward black
simply Retreats the queen now when you
take it looks great for white X Pawn B4
D4 more control but I think these pawns
stick out like a sore thumb you know
what I I noticed structurally in this
position which is if the pawn were on G2
then maybe white would play you know
Bishop F4 E3 and cover that C4 weakness
because that is a hole in White's
position but once you've played G3 you
really want to play Bishop G2 and then
the bishop doesn't really cover C4 at
all so it becomes even more of a
weakness so the pawn on B4 it looks like
you know white got some extra developing
Moves In fact white did get an extra A3
and B4 because white black went back and
forth with the queen but these are not
useful extra moves these are somewhat
weakening moves of course still roughly
equal position that we might see but
yeah overall a pretty good opening
outcome for nehal the first may be
successful opening outcome that we've
seen in this match and Neil he's
spending time here so he is just a
little head in the clock as he continues
to think about this move it's only five
moves in but we have a position that
should be new to both players it's kind
of rare territory I do love the choice
and I think that nihil he should keep
playing quickly CD4 he has made that
choice he could have done that though in
five seconds Bobby yeah but he's still
keeping a slight lead on the clock
although Wesley's starting to pick up
the pace because course A3 forecasted
his intentions to play B4 there was no
other point to that move besides playing
B4 and recapturing with the with the c
pod on D4 so now Niha will decide where
to put his Queen d8 looks like a very
logical square but of course black does
have a choice here right you can go
anywhere on that dag and I don't think
the queen well maybe it can go all the
way to H5 trying to hope for a pawn push
and get on the light Square so there are
different options for Niha I just don't
like the fact that he's now down the
clock he built in a minute and a half
lead and it's evaporated very quickly
yeah that's true I I think that Queen d8
like this is not a critical decision in
the game you might as well make this
decision quickly because whether it's
Queen C7 or queen d8 it's not going to
make a huge difference in the evaluation
of the position something like Queen H5
yeah it might be tempting but it's
rather risky as well and and probably
not what black wants to go for
well many options here but with game
five well underway let's bring in Anish
giri won the semi-finalists here in the
cgc to join us to commentate for a while
Anish are you liking what you're seeing
from nehal thus far thank you guys first
of all good to be back with you yeah I
do like what I'm saying I do like what
I'm seeing
um this is a interesting idea to provoke
before I was even thinking to go back to
d8 then go D5 and you've got this week
C4 Square you see these things with
colors reverse sometimes yeah I mean the
queen on B6 I feel like it's a little
bit out in the open Queen D is what Fabi
and I were talking about and you both
mentioned the C4 Square because when
pawns are two squares away from each
other look at the square in between uh
but fobby Knight F6 played I'm you still
feeling Black's position or do you think
that and Wesley has enough time to uh
cover the weak squares well one thing I
don't like very much is a queen on B6
it's going to run into Knight A4 ideas
potentially after Knight C3 I don't know
what it's doing there because it's not
attacking anything and the other thing
is it doesn't support the pawn on D5
when black plays D5 for so for example
Knight C3 D5 here black would rather
have a little bit of extra support with
that pawn with the queen on d8 now for
example Bishop G5 is a bit annoying
because how do you defend that pawn if
you play E6 your Bishop is a little bit
out of on C8 is a little bit cut out of
the game it feels like Queen B6 was just
a waste of you know half a tempo for
black I agree and well we somebody we
saw bring their Queen to its starting
Square was a niche when you played this
beautiful queen D1 movement how
difficult are those moves to play
especially in the heat of a match where
you are down two full points yeah I
think we see the Nihao slightly
unfamiliar with this particular type of
structures but he's going for entirely
different approach he's doing sort of a
pure defense-ish thing without the C
pose I don't know how that's gonna play
out I think it's a very dubious approach
um I'm starting to likewise position I
think it's both good but also pretty
safe right I think this Knight belonged
on B6 right if the queen were on d8 this
Knight could hop around here into that
C4 square that you two were indicating
is a weakness in White's Camp I'm just
struggling because A5 seems logical but
at the same time white can just combat
that with the pawn push to B5 and the
Knight on B8 looks silly
Flavia what do you think yeah I'm I'm
wondering more generally Anish what do
you think about
the player's nerves does will Wesley's
nerves hold up is he a player who's a
bit nervous in these critical situations
or a player who can stay calm
a little bit nervous but I think as you
know as a player yourself
um even when you're nervous you do need
a question to be asked on the board I
mean just because you're nervous you're
not going to Fumble over and drop your
head on the resign button uh you're
gonna keep making moves but if there are
questions on the board that are not easy
to answer then the nerves come in that's
where you make a mistake okay well I
think a big question right now is the
move D5 The Bishop's on E6 that Bishop
would probably like to go to C4 bring a
rook to C8 so D5 looks scary because the
Bishops opens up on the long diagonal
but is that a move that you would make
Bobby
well I would be a bit nervous not
because of the tactics because the
tactics very clearly work out in White's
favor after let's say D5 Knight takes D5
Knight takes D5 Bishop takes D5 Queen D5
like gets excited for a second I took a
rook and A1 but then Bishop to E3
happens and white regains a piece with
very likely a winning position so the
tactics are easy but the positional
aspect of it is a little bit more
difficult to assess because the pawn D5
is extended and if black like makes a
move let's say Bishop F5 or G4 it's not
exactly clear where the bishop goes but
then black has easy development with
Knight D7 and putting some pressure on
Knight on C3 so it becomes a little bit
concrete and difficult to assess but on
the other hand black is also wasting a
lot of time and again the queen on B6
Bishop to E3 might come and put in
Bishop on D4 potentially black did lose
some time with that uh Queen on B6
rather than d8 you are a Wesley so
Whisperer he does not play D5 he choose
Bishop B2 and issue a fan of this
decision
well the point Fabi was making about D5
indeed is a move that it's very
responsible you open diagonal but I
think I feel in the early opening stage
especially when you can get moves with
Tempo attacking other pieces usually
they're good so D5 and Bishop E3 they
would come with Tempo and that that
makes a difference and I think that's
that felt more right Bishop B2 a little
more timid I mean white has certain
commitments already in terms of
strategical weaknesses the C4 square is
weak and I don't think white should play
it all too slowly because if Black Goes
Rook fc8 Queen dropping back to d8 then
by the way the queen B6 would make some
sense because you got the F Rook out and
then maybe 96 94 so black has potential
and I think white has to I I would feel
like this move D5 like it's I still want
to play D5 honestly I regret Bishop B2
but D5 feels feels like a right move oh
you use the word timid and he played
with H3 and also in the evaluation bar
it went from Edge for white to near
equality but it's dynamic position so
Fabi another move that doesn't seem to
threaten anything of nihals and it's a
quiet move so do you think that Wesley's
a little bit nervous well I think that
it looks like white has a space
Advantage white has the you know black
has a little bit of a passive position
that's how it looks on first side but I
like the word you use Dynamic I think in
fact that nihal is taking a page out of
Jeff goldblum's book from Jurassic Park
you know when you have this like Laden
energy your pieces sometimes tend to
break free and that's what I think he's
looking for Wow reference I did not see
coming in a niche you mentioned Rook F
to C8 Queen can slide back to d8 Knight
to B6 do you think that Neil's gonna
start with Rook have to C8 here
yeah I think the movie H3
um it sort of highlights the fact that
Bishop only six has less squares so I
think he pretends that D5 is a threat
now the question is it a threat because
D5 Bishop moves to F5 G4 oops sorry
that's me well when Bishop has to move
to E4
G5 almost wins material but not quite so
let's say black mix with like roofs yeah
that's what the point I'm trying to so
D5 Bishop F5
and Bishop is short on squares maybe
Knight D4 traps the bishop for a trade I
have a tactical suggestion but I'm not
sure it works it looks a bit crazy after
D5 is there Knight takes D5 trying to
calculate this Knight D5 Bishop D5
Bishop G7 Bishop F3
Bishop D4 Bishop E2 some kind of crazy
stuff happens probably doesn't work out
for Black 2 here yeah and indeed the
variant and that might be the end of
Black's position although what if I take
and you take here and I take here what's
the material count you get a ton of
Pawns and I feel like for the queen it's
worth it is that a bishop or a vacuum
cleaner didn't it just like take half of
white pieces vroom vroom vroom give me
that all of your pieces and I feel like
this is the type of position nehal wants
or reminds me of the game between Wesley
and icaru where Wesley one hit car was
Queen but maybe it wasn't worth it
you guys are silent wow I just stunned
you no I'm just a speechless I'm just
you know like when I whenever I
calculate I use that that uh advice two
steps forward one step back or one step
forward two steps back I forget the
basically steps back are important I'm
really not sure like how we ended up
here what happened let's just let's just
take a moment and go back like first of
all Ruka state has not yet been played I
have a lot of options it just played oh
okay okay okay okay I'm sorry I'm sorry
so now it's a big question will Wesley
go for D5 because he has to both
calculate those lines that we just
looked at which I don't think he would
be worried about because it looks more
like white is the one who would be
better there rather than black but also
after D5 Bishop F5 it's quite a short
position like there's an id4 there
and the bishop is in some slight trouble
95 Knight C4 is something I get in
return for the but normally 95 GF it's
not not a pretty spawn structure I don't
I don't think yeah that's true on the
other hand white pieces are absolutely
terrible like the visual G2 is quite a
bad piece it's obstructed by the pawn
but also the bishop B2 Knight C3 duo
with the Knight coming to C4 doesn't
look very pretty for white no that C4
Square looks tastier than lakas with
applesauce I'm jumping right in and I
think that it's what Wesley's scared
about right here because he has not
moved at The Rook FC and he is ahead on
the clock so a niche I think we're
talking in terms about tactics and
strategy at the moment D5 feels like the
principal move but it could really
backfire as we just showed the line
where the E5 Square becomes blacks for
the taking yeah can I make one General
Point uh something I discovered about
Chess a long long time ago so when both
sides Castle assured and you've got this
tension between the bishop and B2 and
the bishop on G7 now this tension is
very often benefiting black because the
G7 Bishop is protected and the B2 Bishop
is not and that it's kind of a abstract
thing but it matters quite a lot and I
that's one of the reasons why I don't
like this bishop on B2 in the first
place but now that we're here D5 seems
to work I think that position where we
stopped after Bishop 594.95 I'm not
convinced by um you know by all the
arrows you've drawn I I do like why it's
Bishop I think the pollen F5 is very
weak if I ever attack it you will have
to defend it with E6 that will open up
my Bishop weaken on your king Side Pawn
position so I think this particular
position I'm not not against it but
Wesley keeps playing very team at Rook
C1 that is so incredibly timid wow yeah
I think that Wesley is usually such a
concrete player but maybe
you know nerves are getting into play a
bit that he doesn't want to take very
responsible decisions normally we would
call him Wesley X Machina because he's
so concrete he can play like a computer
but you know it doesn't feel like he's
going for the most concrete approach in
this game I didn't expect to think about
Dom Hall Gleason on this show but wow
you made an ex Mach in a reference
hopefully the human can survive that is
Wesley so and B5 is in play so with this
inclusion Niche A5 and B5 here it feels
like this Pawn on B5 can be a straggler
especially if black Thorson's move A4
yeah well once you've played A5 you are
um maybe you have something in mind for
B5 because the pawn indeed is kind of
briefly hanging in the air you do have
to use the the momentum maybe Knight D5
trading the Knight and targeting the
pawn
oh I think what's very important after
Knight D5 if white let's say take 75
Bishop D5 and let's say it goes A4
um black gets to control the central E4
and D5 squares very well with the move
like Knight F6 I think that's that's
always quite nice in these positions
where you neutralize the bishop on jitto
no this looks really good for black in
fact uh this A4 Pawn is a long-term
weakness and you can move your queen
back to d8 bring your knight to B6 and
that is a target so Fabi I'm starting to
like nihal's position and Wesley he
makes the move B5 nihal back on the
clock the one thing I'm a bit concerned
about is nihal we know how strong he is
in bullet but he I feel like he's not
maximizing the potential with his clock
Management on the other hand this is the
best position that he's had from the
opening in the entire match I I mean he
is better with black and he has never
been worse in this game maybe at some
point he was a bit worse but it was an
unclear state but yeah Wesley didn't
really play this very well it feels like
he just doesn't want to take responsible
decisions but at some point you just
have to make responsible decisions and
like a5b5 Wesley forced to do that and
this is a structural change which is
potentially a rather difficult for white
in the long term especially you know the
bishop on G2 it might look like a good
Bishop on a long diagonal but it
completely neglects why it's Queen side
it doesn't have any control over the C4
Square protecting B5 potentially and I
like that idea that you at some point
mentioned to play Queen to d8 and Knight
to B6 because those Knights are really
jumping into the weak squares especially
C4 that is the biggest weakness in
White's position I feel like we're a
great team we're all suggesting these
moves they're happening the Knight comes
D5 a niche you guys kind of uh teaming
up against me I feel this you know I was
going with that to F6 you're both going
to B6 yeah just to continue that line so
takes takes A4 if you go Queen d8 how
bad is it if I play Knight D2 trade the
bishop then bring out the queen to B3 I
don't think it's such a big deal here
but maybe there are some concrete issues
also with root xc1 and I cannot
recapture with the bishop so you're
saying here oh we can't think of the
position you grab the file as well you
grab the file with the Rook C8 and
you've got some momentum going now it's
probably probably slightly better for
black already yeah just to finish the
variation something like this the file
is under blast control A4 is easier to
approach an A5 D4 is needing this
Bishop's defense so yeah it just does
feel like a position with like a
slightly better but let me ask you this
is a realistic variation is this exactly
what Niha wants you couldn't ask for
more having the second move but Fabi
it's not that easy a position to
actually win from here yeah it's a
position which is based on very small
margins so black has an advantage it's
pretty clear at this point that black is
the one pressing in the position but
it's a very small one and the lines that
we just looked at they were based on
concretely you know white has to capture
it on C1 with the queen if white gets
absolutely every move to control all the
weaknesses then it's probably going to
turn into a sterile position because
yeah we have one open file the C file
and it's very likely at some point that
all the works were traded down onto the
file that's what happens when you just
have one open file in the position that
you know Rooks love opened files and
they tend to to trade down so yeah he
Wesley played A4 immediately which also
allows Knight to B4 which is an
interesting choice he's not going for
the trade of pieces and to me when I see
the Knight on C3 versus knight on B4 I
think the Knight on B4 is a better piece
so why didn't you want to trade that off
immediately well Anish was advocating
for the trade so a niche A4 played would
you hop that Knight into B4 after nihal
yeah I have to say though the A4
certainly had a point now if you do
trade on C3 you probably need to put
that Bishop on D5 so you us white would
have gained some time so that was the
idea but indeed you allowed Knight
before and before it's an interesting
option I should mention one thing in
this position black has a lot of options
on every move and nihal's time slowly
ticking down and while he is good at
bullet bullet is a game where both sides
have no time it's not it's not a game
where only nihal has no time at that
game he's not that great so um yeah I
think he has to accelerate a little bit
already he's down a couple minutes
position is good but you know the clock
might matter and I feel like Knight
before is just a practical decision
keeping more peace on the board black
has better control of squares and I
always say this when you have good
control squares a little bit more space
you want more pieces because your
opponents pieces for example this bishop
is staring into its own Knight whereas
we're talking about this 1 G7
having a healthier diagonal so Fabi
Knight before is your suggestion let me
ask you a question about night before
because when I see that move I think it
looks great but there's a question about
D5 I'm wondering about D5 because if
Bishop F5 your Bishop might potentially
get trapped it doesn't seem to be
getting trapped but it's it's a little
bit because it can always go to E4 due
to that pin on the diagonal yeah Bishop
G7 it could even even in worst case go
to E4 here maybe there's even something
better tactically speaking but uh you
have to calculate these lines and yeah
knee-hal is getting a little bit lower
on time Wesley likes to keep that
cushion on the clock I've noticed that
even when he has a bad position he wants
to have a healthy time advantage to
either trick your opponent or you know
when it's at let's say absolutely
hopeless you can at least you know try
to conjure up some some tactics and you
can't do that when you're low on time
when you're low on time and losing that
is just pretty much game over well I put
H6 taking away the G5 score I guess from
this Knight maybe just a slow approach
but a niche that tactic that five and I
was showing with this bishop being on B2
being loose you mentioned that that's a
yeah it would just play a part and he
plays H6 so do you think that nehal just
is uncertain about where to go to from
here or do you think in part he's saying
I have the black pieces a draw is okay
even if it's not desired no I don't
think there's a talk about the result at
this point I don't think H6 is uh what I
don't like about the ages I don't like
the combination of spending a lot of
time and playing H6 clearly like if you
play H6 instantly okay you you were
let's say lazy to spend your time and
you just want to make a quick move but
if you spend the time and then play H6
not a good sign I think he was looking
at night before at all kinds of options
and he was like yeah you know what I
don't know what to do I'm not certain
let me just play H6 okay and we see the
trade Queen comes up to D3 in comes E4
C4 B3 all under White's control at least
for the time being I still like Queen 2
Di 8 Knight to B6 let me go after A4
give me the C4 Square I feel like that's
nehal's best chance Bobby but Robert
Queen date is a really tough move it
might be the best one but Knight F6 is
just so natural especially low on time
you might even just play Knight F6
automatically not even calculate the
lines although you realize that if you
have to win this game Knight F6 Knight
D2 followed by the trade of Bishops and
white not having any of his weaknesses
uh under attack you know A4 Lex and I
can't get to it anymore with after it
goes to F6 and C4 is no longer a
weakness because Black's light squared
Bishop is going to get traded off and
white covers at that square with uh more
than one piece so maybe he'll realize
that he can't go for simplifications and
he'll play Queen d8 get the Knight to B6
and Brilliant I mean nihal that's a very
clutch moment to play Queen d8 in that
situation and anise your point just
still holds true E4 almost traps this
bishop right because E4 Bishop E6 there
is no D5 with B2 loose so once more you
uh proved to be the prophet sorry Dania
and this is a really really important
point in the position
yeah and I I want to point out that this
Knight F6 is a very instructive
positional mistake that I was suggesting
uh it's a thematic move when there's
nothing going on on the queen side which
is often the case lift White had the
pawn on B3 on 9a2 Knight F6 would be the
best way to go but here in this
particular post structure on the queen
side the Knight belongs on B6 and it's
really impressive of nihal to figure
that out in this quick time control and
actually go for Queen date not be
tempted by this stupid move I suggested
Knight F6 which is actually really
showing a lack of understanding here so
Queen d8 is really precise 96. now E4 as
you say Ultra almost drops the bishop
but chess is all about almost almost
doesn't count and E4 is a committal move
otherwise because you block the G2
Bishops diagonal and especially whenever
you play D5 which was the case in one of
the lines that we showed if this move D5
doesn't win a piece you've weakened even
more squares you weaken the C5 Square
the E5 Square so you have to really be
careful with these Pawn pushers if they
bring you nothing concrete maybe stay
away from them for a while I feel this
Knight D2 idea and to B3 I'm not you
know if I get Queen to B3 Pawn to E3
trade the right pieces I think white
long term is not doing too badly but
things can get concrete yeah I think
something specific is if Knight D2
trying to trade off the pieces black
will swap just to show this line quickly
Bishop takes Kings and then D5 I always
like to point out upon three squares
away from a knight dominates that Knight
and then it gives black the flexibility
of a knight B6 Knight C4 maneuver as
this game continues I just feel like
White's position is unpleasant even if
it's okay so Fabi I mean black should be
decide for Choice Knight D2 was played
we see those trades and Knight B6 first
so uh you know what do you make of this
decision yeah I have to say if I were
playing with white pieces I wouldn't be
too worried one thing which I noticed is
because of the Bishops the A5 Pawn is a
weakness why we'll play Queen B3 here
almost automatically I think and if the
Rooks are ever traded off because okay
right now the A5 Pawn is covered but if
the Rooks are ever traded off which is
very likely at some point Bishop C3 A5
attacks that pawn and it's very
difficult to defend it and if black is
forced to move the knight from B6 and
play B6 he we can only talk about him
being worse in that case maybe equal but
definitely not better and I don't really
see why black is better in this position
like if white plays E3 here just
covering D4 I don't see Black's plan you
know everything is covered I see like
some Queen E6 idea maybe yeah one more
point so yeah Queen E6 is a very
concrete idea indeed what I was saying
and uh one more point in speaking of
strategy like if you go D5 I have this
bishop A3 uh idea as well where Bishop
on that diagonal after E3 first of
course Bishop on the diagonal will be
pretty good I can kick out the Knight
with Bishop C5 so I think that your only
asset as black is the fact that the A4
Pawn is a little shaky maybe this queen
E6 idea and then the thing is white will
struggle to defend the A4 pawn and fight
for the C file at the same time but uh
my first instinct if I look at this
position I wouldn't be worried that's
why so I have a feeling especially this
Pawn H6 you know here it's kind of clear
that at some point blackplayed H6 and
shouldn't have like it was a waste waste
of a waste of a move okay Queen E6 I
like because it's a Concrete move and
knee Hall goes for it I didn't see
anything else that white could do the
only problem is it's very likely at some
point we will see a trade of the apons
let's say white plays a concrete way and
Wesley I think is going for a rookie at
Rook C8 and probably Rook C1 will be the
follow-up very accurate and black will
probably be forced to trade on C1
because how else do you can test that C
file why we'll take on C1 and actually
the bishop is better on C1 than B2 which
we'll see in the line where black takes
on B3 and takes on A4 Bishop on B2 it
would actually win a pawn because that
Bishop would be attacked with the bishop
on C1 white has time to play Knight
takes A5 and the more pawns we see
traded the more we are we're heading
towards the modro the more draw well you
use the word draw on each that means I
gotta kick you out of Studio we really
appreciate you having here but we say
goodbye to you for now congrats on the
great tournament and good luck in the
rest of the year okay thank you very
much I Got My Punishment thanks guys it
was great it's a great time here hanging
out with you and I'll see you I'll see
you in there
you know hate the word draw but that is
something that nielsar wants to avoid
like Snakes on a Plane there is no
Samuel Jackson coming to save the day
and there is going to be a queen swap
with five but you pointed this out the
bishop on C1 that is essential here
because when these Queens are traded
after Knight takes A4 if the bishop
we're still on B2 it would be under
attack now white can simply take back on
A5 we have liquidation and we have the
word that anisha's used that got him
kicked offset yeah I think that we are
seeing the players heading towards draw
in fact I see Wesley floating towards a
draw like Princess Peach on a parasol
this is heading in a direction which is
very favorable for Wesley in terms of
match situation wow and Wesley's like
Bowser out there you know he isn't the
big bad boss at the end of the day and
this queen trade is on the table Neo
doesn't really want it but he may have
to accept it and that's not good for his
chance in the match while he still will
get two white games Bobby he had an
advantage here and he probably knows he
let it slip a bit Yeah I think this will
be disappointing if he doesn't find a
way to create chances here and also
going low on time now with a minute 30
against 3 minutes and 30 for Wesley it's
going to be very hard to create chances
because I don't see any move besides
Queen takes B3 which is logical you can
try to keep the Queen's on with D5 but
then white can think about Queen C3
potentially attacking A5 and nihal is
going for a drawish line This is heading
towards the Run Knight takes B7 Knight
takes B5 will most likely be played at
this point and the trade of the entire
Queen side symmetrical structure from
the D to the H files symmetrical pieces
no imbalances in the position so very
very likely a draw and a tiny step
closer for Wesley to overall tournament
victory
yeah B7 B5 both under attack both pawns
can be captured I wouldn't be surprised
to see a draw offer from Wesley and
unfortunately for nihal you know he
wants to buy a draw less than I want to
buy a prodigy desk but still in this
position these pawns coming off the
board there's not much life left after
the series of Trades yeah and uh I have
to say just like The Prodigy desk this
is a smart choice for Wesley to head
towards a safe position and a good
result overall if if we see what is very
likely here which I think we will see
yeah uh then we're talking about match
strategy again how will nehal try to
fight back because the match is still on
B6 doesn't change much because the
Knight comes back to either A4 D5 A4 in
this case and the trades are coming uh
Knight to A5 white will just get that
Knight out of you know the potential
Danger Zone in the blacks enemy camp and
we're going to see a draw here yeah
there's not many pieces are made but
Neil might be trying I don't know what
try he can even attempt but he's gonna
bring his King up it's just a
symmetrical Pawn structure five on five
not many pieces remain no weaknesses in
either Camp safabi I don't think that
nihal really believes in his chances
here but if Wesley summer Gets In Time
trouble that's the one thing that Neil
can hang his hat on yeah at least the
time is equalizing a little bit but
again there's too few imbalances in this
position for to create anything black
has maybe the slightly more pleasant
position you could say because the D4 E3
F2 chain is on the dark squared complex
the same as black Stark's uh dark Spirit
Bishop so it's a bit easier for black to
play
um but now Knight B4 is coming a Trader
Knights will be instant draw because
then just too few pieces left so black
will have to try to avoid that traded
Knights if he wants to win but that
night goes to a less active position
Wesley will not be concerned whatsoever
because black really can't create
threats or ideas here to play for a win
no no pawns are weak everything defended
we see a pawn chain from F to D4 we have
a shorter punch in here E7 under attack
the king defends it just not enough
Firepower to go after any of the pieces
but Wesley trades on F5 and why haven't
they offered a draw to one another yet
Fabi this would have already been agree
to draw but just because of a matched
situation knee held it's just not good
for him that this is a draw that's the
only reason they're playing on because
of course between two players of this
strength it's not the result is not
really in question maybe if they both
had you know five seconds then we would
see some sort of uh
commotion some blunders potentially but
even in that case I would still bet on a
draw but they still have plenty of time
I mean one minute 35 seconds it's it's a
lot of time for this position where you
don't really need to make difficult
decisions yeah crazier things have
happened the Night comes into E4 Bishop
back to E1 Knight G5 the pawn would go
up to H4 so I think if you're nihal you
have to somehow go after this pawn and
if the pawn keeps pushing that means
it's closer to the black pieces H5
played by nehal F3 will just kick this
Knight out of here and I think it's
about time Fabi to boot that Knight yeah
you could play F3 you could bring the
Knight back to D3 to potentially go to
F4 and put some pressure on Black's H
Pawn already I would slightly prefer
white because that H5 Pawn is a bit more
of a weakness that can be attacked of
course we're we're still talking about
uh you know the dreaded zero zero zero
that the engine shows with almost any
move where it's very difficult to make
mistakes here even if you blunder H3
like if you play Knight D3 here I don't
even think you can take on H3 maybe
because of f4 and then light is
completely cut off from the game and
might likely be lost still we would
probably see a draw there but I don't
even think black is threading anything
in this position still H4 can't be a
mistake uh you know don't even create
any imbalances just protect all your
pawns put your pieces in defensive
positions and Coast towards a draw well
Wesley plays H4 after big thing now
we're into a bit of a scramble but
Wesley's a fantastic bullet player we
keep praising Nielsen because he's often
the highest rated player on chess.com
but Wesley himself is a fantastic player
with just seconds on the clock yeah
absolutely and Bishop H6 was played
because white black was trying to avoid
White Plain D5 kicking the Knight away
from the control of f4 and then Knight
to F4 if white were to play Knight of
four here he would actually get in this
very serious trouble because black would
take take play King to E6 put the King
on D5 and then we're talking about a
classic very very bad bishop and weak
pawns scenario but of course Wesley
would never go for that further trades
going even closer towards that that draw
Still Nihao is trying and the good thing
from his perspective is that they're
getting a bit lower in time but Knight
F4 is coming next Bishop 6 Knight of
four the trades just keep coming uh one
after the other and yeah I don't think
Wesley is too worried I feel like it's
just in time because if that Bishop had
been to F6 with the King elsewhere there
would not have been Knight F4 as a
saving move instead we see the bishop to
HX if the Knight goes to F4 black will
take with the bishop and the H4 Pawn
will be loose so I do like what nihal is
doing but I also like what Wesley's
doing E5 just training off pawns without
pawns there's no hope to win this game
in Fabi only two left well I think what
we might see is after Knight takes C5
probably the trade of knights and then a
scenario where if white just gets rid of
Black's last E Pawn it doesn't even
matter if he loses the remainder of his
pieces because famously the bishop and
the H Pawn do not win because the bishop
is not on the right colored square that
we say if it was a light squared Bishop
of course that would win but yeah we
just see a complete trade and King
against King fighting to the bear Kings
and a draw and a draw is in the books
that is good news for Wesley so as he
tries to make fetch happen and fetch 200
000 first place prize we see him walking
off the board the computer there and now
he's gonna go to the player area where
he is going to take a deep breath as he
leads now three and a half to one now
Bobby Robert you're not gonna make don't
even try you're not gonna make fetch
happen that's not gonna be a thing
okay well I don't need you to tell me
what to do but Wesley so also doesn't
need any advice he is in charge of this
match he is ahead by the score three and
a half one half and as we see some of
the shots from the game nihal he was
locked in there he played a good game
but it was not enough to overtake Wesley
so overall it was a high quality game
and nihal can look to it as some sort of
tiny moral victory in terms of him
playing for a win with the black pieces
and getting a comfortable position and
Out playing Wesley in uh some parts of
the game still Wesley was never in
serious danger I don't think he was ever
super worried but yeah Wesley was a
little bit worse and on the back foot in
this game he certainly was and there
were some big moments in that game Fabi
where Wesley could have taken the
decision to push upon create some more
problems in his position but also gain
some things and I think this is a good
place to start because he made the move
Bishop B2 but Bobby D5 was the move that
we kept talking about here in the booth
I think Wesley showed some slight nerves
around these opening stages because he
didn't want to over commit but I think
what he did against Hikaru was better
when he was ready to push his pawns and
punish Hikaru for very risky opening
play he should have done the same thing
in this game instead he just wanted to
you know keep it as controlled contained
as possible not overextend at all but
sometimes it's not the right decision
even you know we say when you need to
draw sometimes it's best to play for a
win because you you should play the best
quality moves if you get an advantage
you also have that buffer of even if I
lose my advantage it's I'm still not
worse well if it's an equal position or
a slightly worse position for you you
don't have that buffer anymore then you
have to play Super accurate to hold the
balance yeah here D5 the point everybody
is that once this bishop moves away say
the F5 or G4 this bishop come up to E3
into D4 more active squares for the
white pieces compared to the game Fabi
where after Bishop B2 after this series
of moves here it just felt like black
was the side for Choice already posing
problems against White's pawns yeah I
like the way that nihal was handling
this for a long point I think there was
only one moment where he will look back
with some regret in this game which was
if we go down the road a few moves the
move H6 this is a slow move again it
felt a bit nervy like I don't want to
spoil my position I don't want to do
anything too responsible and Knight to
B4 was probably the way it's a bit scary
because you allow D5 and some potential
tactics and maybe Nihao was thinking to
almost a game low on time I shouldn't
allow tactics but the tactics were
working for black and Knight to B4 would
have left that very awkward Knight on C3
and also kept the pieces on the board
which would have created potentially
more winning chances right this bishop
loose on B2 as Anish was pointing out
that was essentially you take the bishop
on e4 you lose the bishop 1v2 you'll see
the evaluation bar go in Black's favor
with the queen side edge so that was
overlooked and after that it was pretty
steady draw because the knights were
traded and after that Wesley so needed
no help to secure the half point so that
is it from game five here in the cast
with we're gonna send it over back to
you Danny and the fellows thank you
Robert and Favi we are now joined by
Amon Hamilton Danny wrench James Canty
back in his chair and Levy Rosman Gotham
chess on the edge game five is in the
books it was uh smooth and as peaceful
as a sponge bath let's take a look at
the score we've got three and a half one
and a half a lead for Wesley so he's
just uh holding on and uh gonna try to
he'd like this thing to be a draw the
whole way out if he could so let's talk
about game five I'm on I'm gonna start
with you Wesley said his favorite animal
was an armadillo he just tucked up and
defended there rolled up real nice he
did and you know what Danny that's all
he needs to do uh you know you don't
want to get into that mentality of oh I
just need to draw so I'm going to play
for a draw but I think Wesley probably
is the best at doing that I think he you
know he wanted a draw but he didn't play
in a way that he gave up too much that
being said I think Nihao got a little
bit of something but Wesley is just one
of the best defenders in chess is it too
little too late or is Nihao feeling a
little bit of momentum right now yeah
they know momentum this thing's done bro
is this uh in fact a shout out to Big
Flex test right when he came with the uh
with the movie references right mine is
uh the Neil he's like one he's the
Matrix right he's literally the one
right now it reminds me of the scene
right when like Neo got shot and then
he's like oh he's dead but he woke up
and then he started doing this like
blocking everything one arm that's how
it feels like Wesley you just can't hit
him you can't even do anything to him
right now and he's like a game away from
clinching the whole thing yeah the nehal
game I think was like a moral Victory he
played like a really nice game got a
good position with black but I still
feel like he's just a little hesitant
you can really feel the tension in the
in the games that they're playing
Wesley's just trying to neutralize like
you said just trying to get it down to
the draws get that four and a half magic
number that was a nice game for nehal
but it came five games too late right
like right so he's got two more games to
strike I think the next game he's gonna
go all out so it might be over or he
might make the comments it's too late
for moral victories yeah right even if
he played well I mean what about the
next game what do you do you got to get
a real victory yeah you need to get a
real Victory I'm we might mentioned it
earlier in the pre-show Danny yeah
looking for maybe that sort of you know
London system maybe offbeat sideline
there he needs to generate something
with white because honestly speaking as
as Levy indicated that's a great game
with the black PC it's just not a great
game for the match when you're down two
points you can't pat yourself on the
back for helping Wesley get half a point
closer to that result he needs yeah the
Knight F3 B3 thing like the Hikaru
system yesterday in game four just
seemed like kind of an odd way to go I
really thought that nehal like plays D4
okay don't play the London system but
play a nimso Indian right the forcing
line just keep some pieces on the board
I'm really surprised he didn't go for it
I'm predicting it for a game what is it
six but I don't know I really at this
point nothing he all does as predictable
anymore yeah you can't hit him again
it's like this Wesley's just blocking
everything and then so if I'm knee-haul
here I'm like well you know what look
I'm just going here in the last game
have some fun with it and think about
what I'm gonna spend this hundred
thousand I didn't get the last game
okay all right right well that's right
it won't be the last game but it feels
like it's gonna be the last game really
though I'll be looking I'll be thinking
about
the other way to look at it though is
like as impossible as this task is you
have to start with one game you have to
start with one step at a time drawing
with black would be the chess thing to
do and you take your chances with white
that's what top Grand Masters do he now
has the white pieces and we're gonna see
what game six gets us all right we've
been lucky enough to spend a bunch of
time with Wesley so this week before the
tournament began Nemo sat down with
Wesley who was very candid about his
expectations for the cgc finals
okay
I'm very excited I mean I have to fight
for my spot because there are always
other players other younger players but
I like I like the game give your bestie
what happens hey I just want to play
some good chef
so Wesley are you excited to be here
this week yeah definitely first it's
good to
be all the people here in chess.com and
I'm very excited because it's the
biggest online chess tournament what are
your own internal expectations for
competing this week I really look
forward
to it you know there are eight games
knockout's my favorite tournament format
okay yeah it's uh interesting because
you know you don't know when you're
going home as long as you don't lose too
many games and you still got a chance
how is preparing for a rapid tournament
like cgc different from preparing for
large over-the-board events six years
ago most of the tournaments were
classical but this year we're really
moving it online also a faster time
controls and speeches so you gotta be
very good bits I'd be very good with the
mouth and also practice makes perfect
thank you so much Wesley it's been a
pleasure having you
one of the nicest guys in chess let's
talk about Wesley a little bit in his
year Gotham you do videos covering top
players more than anybody in the world
on your YouTube channel have you done
many Wesley so videos this year and is
it because maybe he hasn't won any
events maybe until now I mean listen uh
I'll do a Wesley video anytime obviously
like one of the most stable players one
of the strongest guys and all the top
players compliment him maybe more than
anybody except like Magnus or let's say
Hikaru in a first format they're all
like oh it's no shame losing to Wesley
yeah I mean if what are you gonna say
tough here like he didn't win the U.S
Championship right Fabiano they didn't
win the World Championship official
random Hikaru they like these are good
people to lose to you know what I mean
uh he was still on the olymp uh I
believe he participated in the Olympics
I mean yeah if he wins this thing that's
that's huge it's the biggest individual
Prize winner of the year right so I
think it's I think it's a pretty solid
year and he's still got World rapid
Blitz if he plays if not all right we'll
see him in 2023. I think it'll be the
biggest first place price he's ever won
in his career right in fact uh two
things one thing is that uh you know I
think Wesley's the biggest troll of
everyone I think he's just you know in a
great way of course I say that because
he's like I'm just not that good and
then you know uh I mean uh yeah I didn't
have a good year losing to icaro right I
didn't have a good year at all the U.S
Championship playing still great chess
right glad to have a good year but he'll
Crush you all the time anybody it
doesn't matter who you are basically
even be covered to get here and not at
200 000 that's nice he won um I won 20
000 the same year he won 100K so he was
21 years old the biggest prize he has
one I think was that 100K in a
millionaire yeah
he was there yeah I remember watching
you win yeah yeah but he got he's going
to get the oil if he wins he gets 200
000 here so that's double so I'm gonna
have to you know see what he's doing and
go hang out with him you know yeah bring
some Wesley yeah drink something yeah
get real friendly with him
but I mean honestly like Wesley is you
mentioned how humble he is you know we
see it in the interview he's always you
know very critical of himself but he's
also just the nicest guy you see on
camera you know Wesley so and I just
want to confirm that that's Wesley so
off camera as well right you know he's
got time for the fans even just hanging
out you know watching some of the games
just out there in the hall uh you know
with with us and you know any any of the
fans that have dropped by he always has
time for a conversation and you just see
that humility on camera and just want to
reaffirm that that's the real West no it
really is for those who don't know he
really is he hangs out he comes out he's
all smiles he's cheaper he'll take
pictures with anybody and and he he
truly is a sweetheart so all right well
we also met a lot of sweethearts at some
point we've had a small army of
commentators here this week among those
is our good friend and unabashed New
Yorker Levy Rosman recently I had a
chance as I was saying to talk to many
sweethearts in New York who know Levy
and some who do not
how often do you get recognized on the
street if I come to Manhattan and walk
around for an hour I'll probably get
recognized yeah it's pretty crazy okay
well we're gonna we're gonna find that
out right now hi sir uh for a dollar do
you know who this is I don't know I'm
gonna get some musician okay okay pretty
good yes he is an artist okay he's an
artist who plays a game what game would
he play the game of Kings
nope don't know it okay hi sir do you
know who this is for a dollar negative
negative okay cool good talk though
you know who I am for a dog oh my god
dude this is yeah of course love it okay
dude what take two dollars are you
serious yeah hey do you know who this is
for a dollar yes who is it dude that's
Levy yeah totally Rosman that's right
there you go for ten dollars you know
who I am
okay
I am the chess.com guy but do you know
who this is
there's a dollar for knowing who I was
for a dollar do you know who this is
dude it's Jake no it's close though keep
guessing Tommy actor actor all right
okay yeah yeah what type of acting
um comedy comedy okay really yeah not
really but I was like magician oh yeah
that's the third magician we've got so
thank you this is great it's the shirt
it's the shirt right it's got to be the
shirt okay hi for a dollar do you know
who this is
look closely it's a chess player that's
right who is he Levy you want a dollar
okay thanks man good job he got it and
you knew you were acting disinterested
but I saw you I see the chest in you
know can we just appreciate how many
people said you look like a magician
what was that man I guess it was the
spots on the shirt I don't know I I like
that shirt a lot and it's funny because
people are like oh it's like a magician
shirt and I'm like dying inside because
that was not the goal of the shirts you
know what I'm saying but uh it it's a
nice shirt I'm going to continue to wear
it very comfortable very flowy I love
how nonchalant people work yeah and
they're also nonchalant in Toronto I was
walking home today from from like a
bagel coffee shop and some dude was like
what's up Levy like I don't what I don't
know we don't know any jokes
it's fine it's just there was just no
shock value he was yeah what's up man I
like your videos I'm like okay all right
have a nice day at work so yeah
sometimes people are Supernatural
sometimes they're like trembling and
really nervous that's also like kind of
adorable you know you take the selfie
for them because otherwise the phone's
going to fall out of there and I'm sure
you guys have like had to do this too
it's like it's cute you got both sides
not quite as not quite as many people
recognize that I mean honestly but you
know people wear that shirt again
without knowing this is the magician
here you got a shirt that's your
magician shirt ah no in fact I just got
the ones that would show the arms the
short sleeves so I can like just Flex
like flexi cell does yeah okay me and
him got we got the same wardrobe so you
know Saturdays we shop all right well as
good of a job as you've done with us
Levy this week we hear the city of
Toronto is not pleased with you so we
thought we would give you a chance to
apologize Levy the floor is yours
yep so I just want to say uh I've been
in New Yorker for about 20 years now and
as a New Yorker I feel as though it's my
status to gatekeep the elite status of
other large metropolitan cities I've
made fun of Toronto quite a bit I've
said it wants to be the New York of
Canada and now that I've been here for a
week I've realized that I actually can't
be more wrong Toronto's great it might
be one of the best cities I've ever been
in I've taken walks left right up down
and I've gotten great food I've met some
really great people and the
transportation is amazing and I just
want to say sorry I'm sorry for making
fun of your city and one more thing New
York is super overrated so that's all I
have to say and you know chess is about
learning from your mistakes and I'm
learning from my mistakes I'm sorry a
month too by the way you accept his
apologies
I'm actually the only one in Toronto so
I'm the only person here the
representative the spokesperson I will
accept the apology but I'm just gonna
say this all started with one bagel I
think had a bagel compared it to New
York and realized you know what listen
we've got some good stuff up here he's
really bad all right well I'm sure the
city of Toronto and the people of Canada
feel much better now but before we take
a break that was Brave Levy and we're
going to remind everybody that brave
means private browsing and so much more
by default Brave blocks ads and trackers
on every page and video you visit even
on YouTube that's right no ads means up
to three times faster page loads faster
streaming faster playback faster Gotham
chess videos it means 35 percent longer
battery life while saving on mobile data
and internet bandwidth for Android iOS
and desktop get the best browser for
gamers streamers and creators switching
60 seconds at brave.com chess much more
to come from day two of our cgc title
match we could be close to crowning a
champion and giving away two hundred
thousand dollars subscribers stick
around for much much more exclusive
content right here on Twitch
foreign
[Music]
what's up
honestly today Wesley just played
amazing chess I'm just very upset about
the third game which I think I totally
outplayed him but then then he showed
some great defense and of course I
should have just taken the drive then
but I just got too carried away and
like with four seconds of course I
should take a draw it's very basic
mistake and against a player like Wesley
it does not go unpunished so don't just
uh great play by him and I just hope to
put up a good fight tomorrow does it
give you a little bit of uh Solace that
you were better in that game and if you
had converted this would actually be an
equal match right now does that give you
some some hope for tomorrow
um not particularly but uh I'm just I'm
just happy that sort of like more
ambitious than ever just
I'm going a lot not something I usually
do so
just
happy that I'm fighting what would you
put your chances at at let's say getting
to at least an Armageddon tomorrow
objectively it's not very high but I'll
just try to
start from zero and just try to forget
today and
try to put up my best chest tomorrow
hey uh Grandmaster nihal Thorin you know
I've read your biography and I can't
find any sports that you're into I kind
of like Ping Pong ping pong you say well
today is your lucky day let's get it on
yes so I guess you have a better chance
here than in chess yeah he's actually
right but okay
[Music]
foreign
so Robert bucknelli yeah loves I love I
love cannoli too can't can't even
describe how much that wants them
hey Danny what are you doing there
nobody puts Danny in the corner
come over here
[Music]
foreign
thank you
welcome back to Toronto and the cgc
title match we travel inside the
gameplay Hall and that ladies and
gentlemen is the cgc championship trophy
which will be awarded later today also
to be awarded the mouth-watering 200
000 first place prize in front of you is
what we have given out thus far awesome
prizes to all of the players second
place will receive 100 G's not too
shabby either welcome everybody I'm
alongside International Master Levy
Rosman the one the only Levy it's been
such a pleasure commentating the games
with you I'm sad it's the last day but
I'm happy that we get to commentate
another game yeah me too listen man it's
been such a great time here in Toronto
alongside you and your effervescent
personality like that you're right off
the bat
listen that was a uh that was a tough
first game today right that was a hell
striking back a little bit but he still
only got a draw and he's still down two
points he's still down two points Wesley
more than happy to draw with the white
pieces he was cool he was calm he was
collected if he reaches four and a half
points he wins the cgc title match all
he needs Levy is just one more Point
another view of the trophy and we are
about to begin seat belts fastened yeah
that's absolutely right in some sort of
uh you know when teams compete for
playoffs right in baseball there's
something called like a magic number
well right now we are in a match
situation of that sort there is a spot
here where the match could end Wesley
now has to put the game away uh with the
black pieces he most certainly does we
look at our rapid insights their wild
accuracy by both players and a lot of
wild games uh by both players you know
what there's not a lot of Levy bad moves
right that's exactly right and nehal is
gonna have to hope for some bad moves
right as we're about to boot up game
number six over here uh nehal really
games go to end games that he can win in
scrambles it was a similar strategy that
Hikaru adopted versus Wesley that's
exactly right now I go I called for a
nimso Indian are we gonna get the move
three Knight C3 no we're gonna get a
repeat of the move he played against
Niche Bishop f4 on the board do you
think Wesley prepared for that yeah he
did I mean they're repeating it and
they're repeating oh look how quickly he
took with the queen that was a statement
move that was a statement move and uh if
we just I'm just gonna very very quickly
show off to the move Knight Knight D2
this is the move that has been played
many many times that's not on the board
right now the queen took and then went
straight back and Wesley's like thanks
man I'm up upon after eight moves yeah
what you got and most importantly Anish
took C takes C4 later on the hall pushed
his Pawn to E5 which he does now as well
now Levy here the type of position
fundamentally changes just because
you've shifted the pawn from D4 back to
C5 the center is wide open and I would
imagine that that favors the side that's
up material that's exactly right it's
kind of why Wesley has a right smile on
his face and 11 seconds more on the
clock than he started the game with
ladies and gentlemen that is why they
have the two second bonus and that's
exactly why he has 15 11 on the clock he
knew this was coming and the thing about
playing these Sidelines on move three
that are potentially dubious is that you
play them once you do not play them
again at least not in a 15 minute format
that's why Wesley's smiling and maybe A3
is going to come as a surprise now
here's one of the two things that's
gonna happen either nehal and Wesley
know the exact same thing for 20 moves
and it will just be a draw or now's like
oh my God he knows everything now I'm
gonna take a risk and it's gonna fail in
spectacular fashion I can see why nihal
repeated Bishop F4 I mean he's
frustrated he played the Catalan that
didn't work he's played all sorts of
stuff that hasn't worked he has repeated
lines before in the cgc uh he played the
modern on more than one occasion and
reached the kinds of positions he wants
to reach but this is such a risky Choice
precisely because you're sacrificing
upon and we both know Levy that this
sacrifice has to be on sound if it was
sound all of the vultures at the top
would have been playing this for many
years that's exactly right there would
have been books and articles and
magazines written on this but the truth
is that black is just up a pawn and
white is kind of Desperately struggling
to prove what they have for that pawn
well let's try to figure out what nihal
is saying he has for the pawn what jumps
out at me and you can correct me if I'm
wrong this Pawn on E5 is is an asset
it's clamping down on some Central
scores it's making it harder for black
to breathe in the center that Bishop on
D3 is aiming at the H7 Pawn so one idea
that jumps out at me is in response to
Castle's white could consider a move
that may seem bizarre H4 but this is
actually a very typical attacking idea
and if black develops nonchalantly then
there's kind of a souped-up Greek gift
sacrifice with Bishop H7 and Knight G5
the idea of H4 is to support the Knight
and open the age file
this position after King H6 might still
be unclear but this is the last thing
Wesley wants and this is the first thing
nehal wants exactly right uh and there's
not a huge amount of risk involved here
there's sometimes Greek gift means you
got a winner you lose actually in this
case you might just get a draw right it
might just be a Perpetual check which
doesn't exactly end the match yet but
that would mean that nihal has to win
the rest of the games yeah I mean a draw
here with the white pieces for nehal
would be would be more unpleasant than
uh going on a first date with someone
who's got halitosis so it's out of the
question wow that's your word of the day
yeah halitosis effervescent I love it by
the way I just want to show something
very funny so the move Knight C3 here
looks like it solves all of Black's
problems it's a very funny the move
Knight see-through looks like it solves
all blacks problems it's a very funny
move yeah uh and we have this this
and then this okay and it's pretty like
is it darn good for black yeah yeah yeah
and well the move Knight C3
unfortunately there's Queens too Queen
C2 which is a very funny move and
suddenly everything is defended and
right life is good the Knight has to
ignominiously return back to home base
now Wesley invested uh over a minute a
minute and a half actually and developed
the bishop to D7 I would Hazard a guess
and say that he actually wants to
maintain flexibility with regards to his
King
of course the move H4 lacks a lot of the
luster if black is uncastled maybe
Wesley is contemplating Queen side
Castle I don't think so I think he is
going to Castle kingside it's just that
he's again maintaining maximum
flexibility here that is
that is wow that is quite an idea long
castles so you just completely avoid
this whole Greek gift nonsense that you
play I don't need any of that just
Castle queenside go the other way three
zeros yeah that's exactly right now how
the thing about this position is that
the only reason it's not just a clean
one point advantage to the side that's
up the material worth one point is
because yes exactly as we have been
describing why it has more space why
does more open lines Why does doing a
nice job also restricting enemy piece
play so all these squares are totally
restricted this Knight is just standing
nicely it's not actually doing anything
uh anyhow we'll load up his cannons and
maybe jump in here at some point but uh
such as now yeah exactly yeah literally
at some point being like maybe literally
exactly at this moment uh but of course
it's a very committal decision once you
do that there's no going back and it's
very unlikely the game will somehow
become a draw but Wesley is such a
pragmatic player that he might just
trade a pawn back and be okay yeah I
mean the power of being able to make a
drawn and that almost being tantamount
to a win really cannot be overstated
it's like it gives you super powers and
it makes available certain options that
you wouldn't consider in a normal game
so to your point Knight C4 Knight D6
definitely attempting idea black will
grab that Knight off the board faster
than moist critical deliver that mate on
F2 against xqc that night will be gone
but in instead will be a rather nasty
Pawn on D6 replaced by Knight Neal
starts with a flexible move of his own
he brings the queen out to E2
in the event of castles he also has the
idea of building a battery with Queen E4
and that's what he wants he wants to
provoke a weakness on the king side and
then he wants to Checkmate Wesley on the
H file that looks like a lot of fun to
play in 30 second chess one minute chess
three minute chest five minutes just any
type of Chess Queen E4 H4 H5 is always
good for checkmate uh Wesley with the
move A6 has indicated that he would like
to play B5 true or false uh true okay
well okay A6 is another one I mean
Wesley is adhering to his strategy right
he's playing flexible moves he's kind of
waiting for nihal to put his cards on
the table because at some point nihal is
going to run out of useful moves and
here's the thing Levy if White Castle's
King side you might wonder why White's
not doing that after black castles you
lose the ability to play H4 you can
still make that move but you don't have
that Rook on H1 which is going to lie in
weight so they're almost playing playing
this weird kind of waiting game that's
right yeah neither side wants to Castle
neither side wants to tell the other the
Intel of the position yeah A6 typical
Wesley move and he's tossing the ball
back into nihal's court he's up upon
he's got that Knight on D5 it everything
is good here and hell can basically move
his king or move his Knight and he moves
his King yeah he commits the king to the
king side and there's no H4 anymore I
mean there is but there also isn't
because there's no Rook on H1 exactly
and now Queen E4 is a mate threat but
that's about as scary as Barney the
purple dinosaur I mean that threat can
be defended against with the move G6
while in the defense of millions of kids
yeah he might actually do this hey I was
a Scooby-Doo kind of kid so I wasn't
scared by anything okay the scariest
thing was Scooby-Doo and the Pirate
Island movie that was the peak of
terrifying anyways I saw South Park when
I was 10. that's probably scarred me for
life and that that's why you turned out
to be the way you are exactly yep see
you should have told me this on day one
that we were commentating yeah but you
know surprises are better and that's why
we've been such a great team
you're making me emotional and we're
barely past move 13 castles is on the
board by Wesley nihal is he gonna throw
in the move Queen E4 will that hurt I
don't know I don't know Trends mate
can't be a bad move or maybe it can be a
really bad move I don't know it's uh for
some reason uh it's kind of hesitant
here from from nehal not to play this
move he could still play H4 Knight G5
and just hope for the best but black
just has to play H7 to H6 and there's no
attack yep um and I don't know we've
seen this like this hesitation from
nehal has been ubiquitous throughout
this match I feel like yeah yeah he's I
don't like the expression gotten into
his own head because let's be real the
actual reason Wesley is winning this
match the reason is on the board Wesley
has won this match on the board we can
talk about psychology but at the end of
the day he's played better chess moves
with that said Levy you're right it just
seems like Niha has second guessed
himself in certain moments and Bishop B5
you talked about it he's giving back
upon strategically yeah Wesley just not
letting nehal have any fun that is a
forced Exchange range of at least one
piece and if you don't trade you the
only move you have to not trade is
Knight to C4 right just say I don't want
to trade with you okay well then black
is just going to have a bishop here
Knight C4 played Bishop here forever and
then the knight from B8 could come out
what an interesting strategy Wesley is
adopting here and to help us understand
the strategy more we have the perfect
guest let's have the reigning U.S chess
champion Fabiano caruanna jump into the
booth with us to give his opinion and
call the game Fabian honor to have you
in the studio once again thank you Dania
it's a pleasure to be here okay Knight
C4 is on the board where 15 Moves In
what do you make of what's Happening
thus far who does it favor well the
position is super complicated I was very
surprised by niha's choice because he
already played this line he beat Anish
with it actually guys I had a question
for you do you know if this line has a
name with D4 C4 and Bishop F4 other than
the new Hall variation I don't think it
does actually I think it's one of the
few lines that is common enough to
Warrant a name like one A4 has a name
and this doesn't yeah I think it should
have a name and I was thinking since
it's sort of a hybrid between Bishop F4
and C4 and I love hybrid openings maybe
we could call it the liger
the liger liger the London and the tiger
the London the lion and the tiger the
lion and the tiger lion and the tiger I
thought you were going for London
because Bishop F4 does that make sense
the tricky thing about not naming
openings on Twitch is you gotta you
gotta get out there because someone's
gonna put it up somewhere someone now is
going to make it on Wikipedia Indian
yeah the limbo oh God that doesn't
really roll off the tongue does it yeah
the annoying thing about these Queens
gambits that end up with no names is you
they just get Queen's Gambit decline
like there's no nothing it's just like
various Sidelines
sound effect I mean I I think I
mentioned this the other day the only
the first time I've seen it was uh was
Neiman Robson U.S Championship I'm sure
it's happened before maybe there's even
you know a course out on it some sort of
opening course that like tip people off
that you can do them on There's No
Chorus the move speaks for itself
that that is definitely true but yeah
it's nehal did get an interesting
position it might be a rather dubious
one for white but still it's very
unbalanced imbalanced and he's
showcasing his intention to play Queen
E4 and potentially Knight G5 at some
point with this move H4 yeah it's
interesting that he's played this move
even with no Rook on H1 and he's
repurposing the spawn it used to be an
anchor point for G5 it still might be
but now it's also used as a battering
ram in the event the black plays G6
Knight A5 is on the board Levy I mean
you called this strategy early Wesley's
just going and trading all the pieces on
the queen side nehal won't have anything
left to attack with pretty soon I get
mad on the up on the opponent's behalf
that play Wesley because it's just so
he's so like everything you think you
have he just he just says all right so
do it like executed right so now Queen
E4 might get played uh Wesley will play
G6 and then what and now there's the
threat of trading all the pieces that's
a legitimate threat because you're down
upon with white you can't trade too many
pieces you'll simply lose in the end
game Wesley just gave him a pawn back
and nihal didn't take it so he's not
interested that in making a draw I'm
wondering if maybe Queen E4 G6 and
Knight D6 is some sort of idea at least
you you're down upon but you have
something to show for it a knight on D6
is extremely annoying and if black were
to take then we have a pass Pawn which
might prove to be weak but for the
moment you can't really get rid of it so
it is quite a dangerous Pawn as well
yeah this construction Bishop on G3 Pawn
on D6 is is surprisingly robust and just
to show if yeah black has managed to
trade two miners but he's gone from the
frying pan into the fire this Pawn on D6
it's super unpleasant somehow the
knights are discombobulated Wesley would
have to handle the position with more
Nuance should the position on on D6
appear but just to add to your point
Levy about how calmly Wesley handles
these types of positions I mean I saw
him this morning he was taking a walk
early breathing the crisp Toronto air
sporting a pair of Crocs he looked
comfortable totally unconcerned I mean
the guy is like an Iceman Fabby you have
experienced that many times obviously
yeah I mean Wesley is known as a very
objective accurate player and he was
just not in his uh head a second ago he
was sort of vibing with the position I
guess he seems to be happy with how it's
going
it is still a good outcome I think for
nihal despite maybe the objective
evaluation at least he got a big fight
this is a must win for him like there's
no other way to put it we he just can't
afford a draw of course I mean a loss is
uh you know immediate match over but uh
a draw is almost akin to that as well
whoa whoa he doesn't go to D6 he goes
back to E3 that's only Knight takes E3
forcing Queen takes E3 and then the idea
I guess is that Queen H6 at least is a
very menacing Square for that Queen but
I don't even see what that threatens so
can you can you now just take on D3 and
play something or even Queen B6
immediately there's no need for black to
release the tension first
let's try just go all in Queen H6 Queen
H6 okay what if I just keep training
pieces I take it and then I go Rook idea
but then maybe Rook D6 already
yeah Rook D6 is an idea but I'm
wondering if maybe the other Rook should
go to d8 because then you have Bishop of
eight
Bishop Fade with Bishop G7 potentially
but it mainly chases the queen out of H6
yeah and if at some point white words
play Knight G5 black can comfortably
take that because if white could
recapture with a bishop that's super
dangerous but you know recounting with
something else it doesn't really
threaten black so much glitching off
yeah oh the pawn is blocking in the
bishop there's no Pathway to F6 it's
totally inaccessible Airport's closed
not to mention that okay here
specifically The Rook also hangs but
just just the convenient byproduct of
your entire attack and how by the way it
just does not he I mean he look he looks
locked in but he is his hands are all
over the place he's back and forth like
going leading back getting up to his
monitor but he's Bree you know he's
breathing a lot quite a bit I I think he
also senses that this is the game right
like we're not I I sacrificed the pawn
on move seven and I'm playing this line
specifically because I want to win the
game not because I'm interested in
making any sort of drawn
um why did he not go Knight D6 though
this is the question I I feel like yeah
I'm surprised throughout this match he's
just on the defensive somehow we're a
little bit unsure of when to jump in
against Wesley I think he really wants
to get rid of the Knight on D5 he just
thought it's too strong a defensive
piece covering F6 covering squares like
F4 E3 for the queen to jump into H6 he
just wants to get rid of it at any cost
even though it's a trade of pieces there
are still a lot of pieces on the board
and attacking potential and I'll make a
slight prediction not on the result of
the game but I feel like at some point
in this game Niha will get winning
chances whether that means some sort of
advantage or even like a winning
Advantage I think that will happen
because it feels like a position
especially low on time where it's easy
to lose control and Wesley's hesitating
a bit like Knight takes Z3 just comes to
mind but he doesn't want to allow the
queen potentially to H6 there's that
element of fear in the in the game that
you you don't want to give your opponent
even the counter player or the attack
you just want to kind of trade all the
pieces and go go to the next game and
maybe that psychological element will
lead Wesley astray a bit how much of the
thought process is changed when you're
in a matched situation so it's three and
a half to one and a half like if this
was just an individual game some
classical tournament whatever is it
significantly different than being up
two points and imagine trying to prevent
The Comeback or does it not really
matter you just try to play the position
I think start of a match you don't think
about it too much at this point it just
penetrates their thoughts so much uh
it's completely in both of their heads
uh even maybe more so for Wesley because
he is an inch away from winning the
entire title the giant prize fund The
Prestige everything nihal he's thinking
you know I just need to to get in it but
for sure there were moments in this
match where nihal also got negatively
affected by the match psychology I think
it's more of a negative effect than a
positive one for players usually it kind
of interferes with your play when you
get these thoughts not about the game
the chest the position but the match
situation the uh you know if you're
behind in the score if you're ahead in
the score if you want to preserve your
lead or if you want to make sure that
you know you don't get behind in the
match those kinds of thoughts do
interfere with your play that's really
good insight and I can't emphasize
enough that the difference between the
first and second place prize is 100 G's
it's 100K per second 200k for first
that's a huge sum of money it can't but
interfere to some degree in your
thinking process but Wesley I mean he
continues to play this in such a con
manner for the time being now even for
the nitpickiest of nitpickers it would
be very hard uh to nitpick Wesley's play
this tournament I mean it's been clean
it's been been virtually Flawless with
you know one or two very notable
exceptions but you know Fabi Levy either
of you could comment on this is it fair
to say that you know in insofar as you
can nitpick he's had a couple of games
where his conversion hasn't been all
that clean like I remember his last game
in sikaru that was almost a disaster so
should nihal be hyping himself up by
telling himself that Wesley is getting
nervous right now or is that too much
psychologizing I'll let Bobby go yeah I
think there even though Wesley has been
super impressive throughout the entire
event there are moments that can give me
all hope uh even in in the games
yesterday where you know in the third
game from a worse opening he got into a
winning Advantage he can outplay Wesley
if the right circumstances come to pass
it's not easy and it doesn't happen
often it's not like you know you're
getting better every game in fact it
only really happened that he got a big
chance in one game in this match so far
but still he can look to that with a
degree of optimism as I'll still maybe
get some chances I'm still capable of
getting chances against this guy I
wanted to bring up a point like
obviously we're sitting here waiting to
see if nehal like how he's going to
continue his attack maybe he's going to
get in on the dark squares Fabian a
question for you because obviously you
you've been around you've played people
like Vichy from the past generation
you've played guys like nihal and maybe
even younger I don't know some of those
guys might be younger than nihal from
the current generation uh if I don't
know if this is too complicated of a
question how many like what sample size
of games do you need to see of a person
to nail their playing style
that that's a very interesting question
and uh it's it's difficult to answer
because players you know we we tend to
have these myths about players but
usually chess players have very very
complex Styles it's not like magnus's
likes end games or Hikaru likes you know
sharp positions right that's like
they're they're these
there are these stereotypes about
players uh which you know is natural
like you you see a few games where
Magnus does something incredible and
then game and you think oh he's he's
nine game Wizard which is true for sure
but uh most top players are very
Universal and there are some slight
stylistic differences between people
sometimes there's even major ones but
those don't manifest so clearly in games
because very often uh the main tool that
that strong players have at their
disposal is their calculation as James
Kennedy would say calculation over
everything and that's definitely true at
the top level and when a guy like Wesley
or a guy like nihal calculates they
actually tend to reach similar
conclusions and their calculations they
tend to see a lot of the same lines some
of the differences might be in less
concrete positions or in decisions that
may not even have an objective truth to
them sometimes it's just I like this
type of position more than others but in
many ways uh players play similarly to
another to one another
still a lot of it is psychology also
once that comes into play sometimes
players do crazy things like you you
know you you give Wesley a position one
day where he would never make a mistake
but if it's another day and he's feeling
a bit differently he might make a
mistake in that type of position
what we see by the way speaking the
moves yeah uh what do you think about
Knight D2 as opposed to maybe something
like H5 being a bit more confrontational
we get that this is trying to go to E4
and F6 is it too slow or is it just
right
I see the bar doesn't like it but I do
like it once that Knight gets to F6
that's very scary because if you take
then you have that Eternal uh mating net
around Black's King yeah I think the
engine just looking ahead is always
meeting Knight F6 with Bishop F6 that's
a lot scarier for a human than it is for
a computer because that's not the same
as the situation of the queen on H6 now
that there's a Pawn on F6 the queen
obviously does have a direct Pathway to
H6 so so maybe black needs to position
his Queen to be able to meet Queen H6
with Queen f8 but that's a pretty flimsy
defensive construction I I'm on the same
page I like Knight D2 should Wesley play
as quickly as possible down the default
should he go just like Rook D Rook D4
and rook d8 and try to make niho run out
of fuel before he manages to get his
Knight to F6 yeah I I love this move
Rook to D4 because the problem after
Knight T4 for white is that Knight to C4
comes and the queen has sustained
contact with the Knight on e4 which it
gets a bit awkward and also E5 is
hanging potentially it's falling off
like if Queen E2 I don't immediately see
the problem with Knight takes E5 uh
maybe there is course it's there's some
sort of pin there but I don't
immediately see why black should avoid
that so Knight C4 is very annoying Rook
D4 is very annoying uh you don't want to
play Queen F4 because then your queen
and Bishop they're like a weird sort of
uh
weird position on the 94's pinned as
well so yeah Rook D4 looks like a really
good move but we see Wesley did not play
that he instead dropped his Knight back
to C6 so he's gosh this D4 Square it's
so popular with black pieces more
popular than Troy Bolton in High School
Musical every piece wants a bit of that
D4 square but you could get into a bit
of the I forget what the term is
Superfluous peace situation where you
have one Outpost and you have four
pieces that want to access it so Bobby I
mean I think it's clear that nihal
should play Knight E4 your point about
Knight takes E5 actually being a thing
95 has to be considered in response to
94. yep yeah that's very annoying for
nehal that he has to consider not only
Knight D4 but also Knight takes E5 and
the thing with the Knight on D4 is it's
such a good defensive piece because it
can always come into F5 to cover
potentially G7 if there's like a pawn
white pawn and F6 and queen coming to H6
Knight to five would deal with all those
threats
so Knight D4 is a beautiful Square for
the night I don't think this is a case
of Superfluous pieces because black can
also play put the other work on D5 so
black has a number of everyone's happy
yeah no is there still any Merit for the
White Knight to go to D6 instead of F6
because it's going to start getting
really difficult to get the queen over
here with the Knight just very freely
being able to kick it out so does nehal
have to change the game plan here but
you know what black might go for after
that he might just sack The Exchange
because he has two pawns and a beautiful
Knight on D4 and I feel like it's
relatively risk-free for black in that
in that scenario that's so worth it
illustrating that's such a buzz skill
takes takes just Rook takes D6 again
weaponizing the fact that white uh the
black only needs a drawing and the event
of takes takes B4 blackened support this
very important Cog in the machine with
the move B6 and this just looks so solid
you know as a Soviet Gene with it how
can you lose with a knight like this on
D4 yeah I don't think you can in Black
Will play F6 and E5 the Knight is the
most powerful night that ever existed
it's never going to be booted out of the
center that's exactly right and after
Knight D4 nehal is already down to two
and a half minutes that's a storyline we
haven't mentioned yet this game we've
talked a lot about how comfortable nehal
is in time scrambles but Wesley is his
Kryptonite in every type of position
yeah the time is a serious problem for
anyhow right now because
even if the objective position is
objectively good for black once it's low
on time with King safety being an issue
for black it's very very difficult to
play but if Wesley has that nice buffer
of time he'll make his his play quite a
lot easier so we see what is a very
logical move I think probably Wesley
will oh he plays King G7 instead that's
so clinical he just doesn't want to take
the Knight he just says hey you want to
chill on F6 I'll let you chill on F6
what's going to be your follow-up Queen
G5 I think can be met with H6 and as
nihal contemplates his next move he's
dropped below two minutes Bobby we are
going to release you and let you enjoy
the rest of the show we will see you in
the gameplay haul thank you so much for
joining us thank you for having me here
guys thank you Fabi okay back we go to
the game 90 seconds now on the clock 40
I'll start team G7 is a Wesley so
vintage move right there yeah I I didn't
even think about it like I just thought
you'd obviously take the Knight and now
that you've got a buffer there you know
that the queen isn't going to make it to
H6 will you play exactly the way that I
had in my mind and that's why I'm here
and he's there he plays King to G7 and
queen goes to H3 I mean again this looks
really good if the time situation is
inverse because black has a lot of time
to panic but right now black doesn't I
have just no need to panic it's now for
us to play instantly yeah and Wesley
could push this Pawn up to H5 I mean
White's only idea here is to just I mean
given the opportunity White's gonna play
H5 instantly and the worst case scenario
for black is where the H file opens and
the queen infiltrates H7 something tells
me Wesley's not gonna allow that to
happen I think he might be calculating
H5 G4 at this point we're just going to
see nihal throwing the kitchen sink at
Wesley on the king side that's exactly
right I kind of called it right when I
was in there I but I thought nehal was
going to play three Knight C3 I'm
shocked he hasn't by the way yeah I know
that's the one move he hasn't tried it
it's such a rich opening yeah like
Knight okay at least don't play both
nights right because we know there's
some fours there's some forcing really
sharp lines like in the semi-sarash
nowadays but I'm just so flabbergasted
like why Play Bishop F4 it's really like
a one-time thing it's not something like
I played it too days ago yeah now I'm
gonna play it once again so strange
decision making but a good learning
experience overall and let's just not
forget the match is still not over not
over at all Wesley still has to win the
game or at least draw it and and I like
the way nihal has handled this game the
pawn sacrifice is unobjective he is
worse here I think Wesley is maybe five
or six accurate moves away from winning
this game and the first step is to get
Wesley low on time and and that's
precisely what nihal is doing Wesley
down to four minutes he drops this King
back to h8 and what a tricky move this
is look at that if white plays H5 black
can now play Bishop takes F6 remember
this move was impossible because there
was a king on G7 this would be a
discover check since there's no check
black plays Queen takes F4 and Perry's
HG with the simple FG and the game is
over you have to understand in a
position like this where you have Queen
Bishop Knight two Rooks a bunch of
different pawns to move the king it's
unbelievably after you've just moved it
once a king move creates the threat of
taking the Knight wow I mean that is
just an Exquisite move by Wesley it
Boots the Knight out of F6 uh
E8 just swap the Rooks let's go it's a
it's a very famous bullet technique raid
all the pieces and immediately Slide the
other one over and if you white has two
choices trade all the Rooks or slide
over and nihal has about five miles left
in his gas tank and he needs to drive
cross country and Rook D1 Rook d8 takes
the air out of the building and if
Wesley can get this into a pawn up
ending I mean let's actually also not
forget that a draw doesn't lose the
match for niho so if it gets into a
situation where Niha has no winning
chances that doesn't mean he should
resign he actually should try to save a
draw and then he will have to pull out
two wins on demand but he's had some
actually his best positions of this
entire match have been with the black
pieces exactly so so he does not lose
the match with the draw he shouldn't
just give this away but Rook takes D1
and Rook D it puts Wesley on the cusp of
winning the cgc and one thing I wanted
to mention and there it is Rook D1 and
Rook d8 uh you me and Fabi set history
did you know that wait say that again
like you me and Fabi when he was here
for a few minutes uh we actually made
history how did we make history uh we
were the curliest-haired commentary team
of all time that's I don't think anybody
can even dispute no like second place is
somewhere in I don't even know the
Shadows yep I don't even know where they
are by the way look at the king GH just
look at how he's using his Kink yeah G7
to HD triangulation in the middle game
and the reason that black is not taking
despite actually occupying the square
more than any other on the board is
because there are tactics right there's
tactics onto this queen there are
tactics on the D file as well at the end
the bishop could get pinned to the roof
and there's no reason to even get into
any of that no that's exactly right
that's exactly right if you had taken
twice Queen T3 would have won the piece
another accurate move by Westland that
was the best move it chases the bishop
out of f4 nihal has his back against the
wall if you have to play Bishop H2 oh my
God Levy at that point H6 played he's
placing the business nobody can just
take it and the Knight defense G7 and
you can't take the Knight because the
Rook takes on D1 with check G takes F4
wins the game for Wesley yep he's taking
the four is over G takes that four king
slides over and that's it there's no
Queen G7 it's a blunder of a bishop or I
don't know maybe just a failed sacrifice
but this we might be looking at the
final moves of the chess.com Global
Championship right here there we go
nihal with the final Bluff Wesley does
not buy in G takes F4 and the last gasps
Forney halsar and you can just see it on
Wesley's face he knows it knee-hal knows
it the game is over Wesley breathes a
sigh of relief if he as he is now just
up a bishop he's not about one anymore
zero compensation on the next move he's
taking that night off the board
immediately get out of there nihal grabs
his head oh my God and it's not just
this game that's flying over his mind
it's the entire match no it's the entire
match he did not play like himself the
past few days he's deciding whether to
hit the resign button or make a few more
moves yeah we'll see what he decides
well he's got 30 seconds to make that
decision I think he might throw in a
check on G4 over a mouse slip King h8
does get mated yes King h8 is made in
one yep he does it King f8 instantly the
response by what's he got two minutes on
the clock that's over that's this is it
this is it there is that oh my God
nothing here there is nothing here oh
the top engine move is Knight takes F5
just giving away an entire rook and then
and then a night yeah that's not gonna
happen as time is ticking nehal just
thinking what went wrong the final
seconds of the 2022 cgc the inaugural
Edition happening right now okay he
takes on D1 but now it's just a full
extra Bishop for Wesley yeah we might
get a queen D3 or a queen D5 yeah Queen
takes C5 I think you can just collect
yep collect the pawn defend everything
no back rank Checkmate Wesley enjoying
himself a sigh of relief as he knows
that he just won 200 000 not quite yet
he's a couple moves away Queen takes C5
Queen D7 is nihal's idea by the way I I
don't know that queenie6 okay and Wesley
has the luxury of just chilling out he
can take his time he's up a lot let's
put it this way and
but 100K is on the line this game can
you imagine that in the next couple of
moves he cannot make or break not for
Wesley not for Wesley true not for
Wesley but uh wow yeah he's taking his
time here on Queen takes C5 I think he's
trying to find a suitable response to
Queen D7 he might give a check he might
need to move his Bishop there are ways
to blunder yes but even if you hang the
bishop you might still be in good shape
but he's not gonna do that I think the
surgical way is Queenie one check and
then Queen back to E6 in order to
eliminate the H6 Pawn with check and
once that Pawn's gone then the king is
safe for Life yes Queenie one check it's
a very common technique I like to call
it the boomerang you go oh you check and
he plays Queen D6 also reasonable he
will block the check with the bishop the
king gets some air you can probably even
take on H6 you can you're up so many
Pawns in addition to your extra Bishop I
mean he's also up a pawn at this point
and the only reason Wesley's not playing
moves instantly is because he has 115 on
the clock and uh he just doesn't want to
mess anything up yeah this is a great
lesson for anyone watching even the
greatest in the world in a completely
winning position they take their time
they slow it down they make sure that
every move counts and the bishop I think
is going to swing over to B6 attacking
F2 and then the queen can pile up on F2
and you don't really care about the B7
Pawn you're fine giving it away you do
know Wesley doesn't Queen B6 on the
board he's gone below a minute making it
mildly exciting the only thing Wesley so
can blunder here is a Perpetual check
yep that is it and that's even that is
fine with him and even that is very hard
to blunder yes except like that's it and
that's it that's it ladies and gentlemen
the headphones are taken off for the
last time Wesley so Wesley so is our
champion of the 2022 chess.com Global
Championship here in Toronto all smiles
as Wesley takes the first cgc title and
the 200
000 first prize Levy what a moment what
a moment indeed Wesley so we see they're
holding the 24 Karat 50 pound trophy
that may or may not be accurate massive
congratulations to him he has been
lights out the past two matches I don't
know if anybody has ever deserved a
victory more than Wesley deserves the
cgc title let's review our final score
he wins with a dominant score of four
and a half one and a half it was
basically a wire to wire Victory Levy
yeah it was from game one that Petrov
defense where nihal played prep that
Wesley himself had on the board in St
Louis just a few weeks ago uh to the
final moves of game six it was just all
Wesley You could argue game three had a
couple of tense moments but from that
point forward it was all Wesley
incredibly impressive and he's he's just
been the antithesis of the last two
opponents he most certainly has King
Wesley dominated from the first moment
until the last no matter how you look at
it from the opening preparation
perspective from a converting advantages
perspective from just a keeping his
composure perspective no matter how you
slice it how you spin this is one of the
greatest performances maybe of all time
yeah seriously at these Stakes he's been
tremendous he beats Hikaru in a
neutralizing type of fashion playing
anti-hikaru type of Chess getting him to
play a little uncharacteristically risky
and then taking him down although it was
standing in game eight and in this final
I mean what more can you ask for like
literally what more can you ask for he
did everything right in that match with
the exception of maybe two moves and
that's really impressive in six games
and it's so poetic that you know his
really only big blunder of this entire
tournament occurred in the very first
game against Dimitri and Drake and he
was off to that start we were singing a
completely different tune on Drake and
winning the first game with black maybe
if Dima had converted that position we
would have sung an entirely different
tune the entire event but he didn't and
that's the way that chess works yeah and
just friendly reminder for anybody that
doesn't know what we're talking about
you just got here in the very first game
of this entire event Wesley so was one
move away from losing right maybe two
moves and that's what this is all about
one move can cost you hundreds of
thousands of dollars but he is our
champion he is our champion and our
champion is standing by with Nemo Nemo
to you we go
thank you Levy and Donya congratulations
Wesley on winning the cgc title match
and 200 000 how do you feel after
winning your last game and such a large
sum of money yeah I'm very nervous uh
the last few games were very nerving I I
think on game five actually I actually
was in Turbo like I was misplaying the
position and it's never good but the
last game was much better uh I just
didn't put pressure on myself but I'm
very happy and very pleased to win it
the fifth uh definitely big I mean I
have a lot of people to think I'll thank
them again later but uh
uh it's it's amazing it's great I'm very
grateful to win the first Global Chess
Championship absolutely
I'll played the
or the bishop it for London hybrid were
you
right were you prepared for it did you
look at the lines before yeah definitely
I mean he played it against Anish
two days ago and he I'm not sure I think
I mean it's very very famous line so I
definitely look at it I think I'm not
sure if anyhow played more than one game
with it but uh yeah I was I definitely
came prepared uh I didn't expect him to
repeat that line because it's very
forcing I thought he might go for the
London with Bishop F4 anyway but it was
a nice game I I think uh I knew this
idea beforehand it's Bishop D7 Bishop B5
and the uh I'm not sure if he had any
chances I think 92 was a mistake I mean
the games were certainly interesting but
in game 5 he had real chances to put
pressure like if Magnus Carlson had
black he'd probably win the game like at
some point he had after B5 he had A4 and
then Knight D2 D5 so he had definite
real chances there I wasn't playing well
early today but I did some warm-up Blitz
today and chess.com I also lost my first
couple of games so maybe a warm up helps
you've played a lot of Chess this week
what are some of your biggest takeaways
what was your favorite moment
I will meaning this one yeah
winning this one certainly uh uh
um yeah just just keep trying I I just
finished a tournament Reykjavik didn't
go well uh like I finished fixed place
so it's nice to win from time to time
and I I like to take the opportunity to
thank some people
uh I'd like to first thank my mother and
my family they did a great job
supporting me I'd like to take chess.com
and the sponsors for hosting this
wonderful event uh the players are
treated here like kings basically like
monarch this is the best tournament that
I've ever played in I I think I can say
that honestly and I'm very grateful for
the people that made this happen like my
friend Danny wrench who runs who does
such a magnificent job to to you guys
the commentators thank you also uh shout
out to my fellow players uh Anish giri
and Jan Christoph Duda and also to uh
Fabiano caruana I was thinking last
night I never would have imagined uh a
few years ago that Fabiano would be
commentating on my games
it's just crazy and and fane and uh I
mean he's a super strong player I hope
he doesn't
spend too much time going but I also
like to thank my uh my friend uh Gregory
Joseph and also George Faba they
encouraged me literally
uh before every game they just you know
cheer me up and for a player like me I
kind of need those things also I'd like
to thank Joe did federary who's one of
the best rappers I've ever seen uh and
the chess.com staff and I don't know
older names but particular I guess
Michael brancato for you know running
the show also to Alex Brewer to Simon
McNamara and uh
I guess there's many other people like
to think but a shout out also to Robert
Hess and the other commentators to
Armand Hamilton to Daniel nardinsky to
you
also like to say shout out to my
neighbors in Minnesota and brynmore
they they watch my games uh yesterday
like they spend the entire weekend
watching my games
did a fantastic job it's one of the best
broadcasts that people have ever seen
thank you so much Wesley congratulations
once again and back to you Dania
Nemo applause applause for the winner
our winner Wesley is going to head to
the main set and join Danny and the Gang
while we wait it is time for the brave
move of the day where we highlight a key
move or set of moves that decided the
outcome of one of our matches today and
unsurprisingly we have chosen a moment
from the final game of this inaugural
edition of cgc from Wesley so's winning
game with the black pieces against nihal
sarin this is the position in which
Wesley played a brilliant defensive move
he stands up a pawn but nihal sarin has
developed rather menacing counter play
against his King he threatens to bust
open the king side with H5 and most
importantly the Knight on F6 is
Untouchable due to the Discovery Levy
the Iceman produces yet another
brilliant move yeah he was just
spectacular defensively throughout this
event but specifically in situations
like this he had just brought his King
up instead of capturing the Knight a few
moves ago and here rather than stomping
in a advancement of a pawn with an
advancement of a pawn Wesley played the
cool common collected King 2h8 and this
is our brave move of the day because you
can make multiple King moves you can
allow the attack to come in but the
capture on the Knight and now moving the
king out of that attack would have
threatened Queen takes Bishop he stops a
massive attack on his King by moving his
King to the corner and counter-attacking
the hull precisely at the spot where you
think the king is most vulnerable but he
understands as you very nicely explained
that the threat of Bishop takes F6
disarms White's attack entirely in the
event of H5 black just collects the
bishop on F4 then recaptures on G6 and
whites attack is over Red Rover so nihal
he was forced to drop his Knight back to
E4 this gave Wesley the uh chance that
he needed to knock both of the major
pieces off the board all of the Rooks
are going to be gone and if the Rooks
are traded winnings uh nihal's winning
chances go down to zero the Indian
Grandmaster tried one last trick he's
situated his night on D6 and by the way
a very nice well again I mean the brave
King once again plays King to G8 just
wouldn't stop moving his King and they
were all the best moves the King was the
main defensive pieces like the
goalkeeper scoring all of the goals in
that game yeah he's just like all right
you guys do your thing don't worry I got
you back here yeah King G7 King h8 King
j8 like a little triangle in the last uh
20 moves there he was playing three
times he moved this King I believe it's
incredible but notice how many things
remain behind the scenes we took so much
for granted about Wesley's play even
this move Knight D6 so darn tricky if
you would have taken twice looks like
the worst is behind black everything is
fine black is up two puns but Queen to
D3 was nihal sarin's idea and there's
pins Galore the bishop can't move either
because you lose the queen or because
you lose the Rook for example Bishop
takes that four Queen takes the eight
and white is up in exchange Wesley saw
through all of those trucks instantly I
mean it wasn't even close and instead as
you pointed out Levy maybe our honorary
second Brave move the day King G8 three
of them King G8 G5 shutting down the
king
just another one and she takes F4 is
another Brave it's just that I I saw it
Queen T4 Queen you just have to see that
the Knight is obviously defending the G7
Square yeah I I mean what a display from
Wesley from start to finish in this
match the last 14 games he's just been
amazing you can add a few more in that
on draken Match so really 95 of the
games here he played really well and was
really clutch I mean that's probably a
winning formula it most certainly is you
could really fill a volume with all of
his all of his Brave moves and all of
his incredible moments his play was so
crisp it was so clean it was
Transcendent and let's not forget Levy
this was a rapid time control we're
talking about this as if he just won a
tournament like the Tata steel but this
was a rapid time control which makes the
quality of his playben more incredible
yeah I mean he was just incredible that
first game he almost lost and then he
turned it all around it ended up being a
draw but in his next two matches he was
just I I'm running out of adjective
well we are all out of game so it's a
good time to run out of adjectives folks
that was our brave move of the day
remember it's time to make your move
from chrome to Brave try it now at
brave.com chess
well for the last time folks that is it
for us today it has been a pleasure
crowning a champion with you and chat
Wesley it has been a pleasure covering
your games and calling your play
four International Master Levy Rosman
Levy what a pleasure it's been to
commemorate with you it's been awesome I
had honestly the time of my life for
international Master Levy Rosman I'm
Grandmaster Daniel nerdinski and now we
get it back to the gameplay haul where
Danny and Company have a very special
guest Danny take it away
thank you once again to dania and Levy
and all of our casters all of our
commentators who may not be with us in
these final moments but they are here
I'm on Hamilton is here Fabiano car one
is here on the end and of course we have
a chess.com Global Champion right here
before we talk to Wesley let's take a
look at our bracket one more time we
push to our final and then we move our
champion's name all the way through
Wesley so is our champion
he is the first ever chess.com Global
champion and we uh we'll have that we'll
have that there right uh in just a
second
um all right well first things first as
we get Wesley set up here uh for his
name to go through Wesley
I'm gonna ask you how you how you
feeling there he is there yeah
yeah I like that man I like everybody
everybody
huge huge shout out first and foremost
to the city of Toronto and all the fans
they have showed up daily to remind me
how much I screwed up to not have live
ticket sales for this event but so many
of them are with us now and we we gave
them the special treat of doing so but
all right Wesley we got to get gotta get
to you man you did it yeah I'm very
happy you've won the global Chess
Championship when you and I were in Oslo
in 2019 I felt like there was a similar
vibe in every interview I saw it's like
you didn't even believe it yourself how
well you were playing throughout almost
had to convince you when you won the
tournament that you did it do I need to
convince you again that you just won an
event in its inaugural season and you
are a global Champion uh yeah probably
not the day but tomorrow I'm sinking in
it's sinking in yeah I'm very pleased
and very happy and I'm very grateful to
the people also to you Danny I mean you
always encourage me I remember our
little talk in also that we had three
years ago it really helped a lot uh I
mean I'm doing nine year 29 years old
obviously there's still some stuff that
I want to achieve my chef yeah like try
to improve my classical rating and all
the good stuff right but the last couple
three weeks have been very rough on me I
think at some point all the losses just
sank in at some point you just want to
do better and play better and it's
incredible winning this also to not have
lost any games uh it's just totally
unbelievable yeah on the first place I
uh uh I actually objectively should have
lost the match with the official so you
know the history would have been so much
different if you have incredible all the
coincidences will happen you played
incredible uh we're going to talk a lot
about your management how about
everything we can well we have you I
mean do you ever won two hundred
thousand dollars no one go
I think I played in Qatar open once I
won 150 for 10 for 10 days
okay well you've moved up in the world
yeah it is back in 2015 all right
playing the guitar hoping Bobby I want
to ask you uh what questions you have
for your your Amer your U.S Olympian
American teammate a guy you played chess
with so many times and just we've played
a lot of tournaments recently actually
Wesley you mentioned that uh some of the
last few tournaments haven't gone so
well you have you've struggled a bit
recently did that motivate you more yeah
definitely I guess
uh
uh I mean of course you know
the chess chess.com staff my mother have
cheered me up a lot but uh
I think without those losses I wouldn't
have won today for sure why is that yes
part uh because
you know when you're enjoying life when
you're when you have everything you
really need in life and then when you're
just enjoying relaxing you know watching
movies reading books you feel like
everything's going well like the last
few months I've just been reading the
news and all that and you know following
some puzzles and I thought that the US
Championship would go decently but it
didn't
and you know at some point I guess
losing to Christopher you really pushed
me yeah and this is also the 50th
anniversary of the Fishers pasty match
so I was actually reading all about
Bobby Fischer and all about the books I
can get about him I'm just amazed and
impressed by the fact that when Fisher
was eight years old he already knew what
he was going to be and that used to be
world champion I realized that uh
you know you really gotta you really
gotta push yourself you really gotta
work but uh
yeah anyway
um
fa fa fed uh you know sometimes we play
well sometimes you don't but
you just try to improve and keep getting
better I'm
you know I'm very honored to be fitting
beside the former World Challenger
Fabiano caruana here you know
uh he's not that big of a deal don't
worry
yeah if you if you want 2018 then things
would be now you're a global champion
how's that feel yeah
somebody say Global is more powerful
than world
together I didn't get that way I think
if hiker won the 960 right that's only
world right yeah this is bigger yeah but
you've now wanted you've won a few day
world title now you've won a global
Title Iman what does he need to do next
well I mean Wesley I was going to ask
you you keep referencing this Jeffrey
Zhang match like I wanted to ask you
about the formats kind of unique like
another knockout tournament and you know
do you really think that that ultimately
crowns you know the strongest player at
the end because it's very unforgiving
yeah that's true it's hard to say it's
not for me to decide uh because there
are different time controls I think the
format is fine four games is a pretty
decent amount I don't know what Fabi
thinks but I think four games maybe it's
okay for six games eight games is
obviously preferable but it's too long
at home uh
uh it depends what on what time format
you're referring to as the strongest
player and I mean if you start the
tournament all over again things happen
yeah making it through this Gauntlet to
uh to win the trophy and also when the
title is nice but you also take home two
hundred thousand dollars as we look at
the final standings Let's uh see all the
money that our players took home and
Wesley tell me your thoughts about that
first place prize I know I already said
it's the most money you've ever won you
confirm yeah but you know you could
probably buy a house with them yeah
absolutely it's like literally all my
earnings this year and then I won it in
one day
so yeah I'm very grateful to the
sponsors obviously this is
yeah you know people put up a lot of
money for this stuff you got best
production crew he got laughs
Electronics here you heard a lot of
people
so that's why I said this one the best
or the best so I'm very grateful to
I appreciate that for all that uh
and I think the most money I've won
before was millionaire just eight years
ago yeah a long time ago yeah that was
the tournament that helped you decide
that you actually wanted to take your
professional career you were at Webster
University at the time for those who
don't remember Wesley so wins the
millionaire open and that was the push
you needed to kind of maybe get off the
fence right and really go all in at the
time you you committed fully to being a
player and if you have any regrets about
that no okay
not one bit uh
being at your chest professional is kind
of a weird life yeah but uh
but it's nice as long as you're trying
to achieve something I'm you know
it's uh it's also a fun life you know
trying to trying to improve uh getting
better because after all having a nine
to my job is quite boring doing the same
thing I agree let me ask you something
you said that some of the early matches
you were playing in this tournament were
rather difficult and you got some close
calls there does that give you extra
confidence because your match against
Hikaru was so smooth compared to some of
the earlier moments you had against
let's say on Drake and or against
Jeffrey as you mentioned
uh yeah it's it's interesting I played
so much better here than
I played during the qualifier because
the first round I played Dennis lasavik
and I lost the second game and I was
also looking in the fourth games I
almost died due to and I almost didn't
make it then I played Evancho and I
flagged him every game
[Laughter]
yeah
because I watch his games on chess 24
and it's always in time travel also
against three rubs and it was in time
when you're playing older people I guess
like from Nikita
yeah but some of them did well some of
the well in this event chromic and
Chucky give them their credit but yeah
right yep I also like to make a big
shout out to nihal he played
fantastically well during the entire
tournament like he was literally
lower feet than every single one of his
opponent but he beat them all kramnik
Ding and ish yep actually to elaborate a
bit on that because you mentioned that
you thought about that before you're
playing Evancho when whenever you have
these matches against a specific
opponent are you trying to think up a
match strategy for all of them
um a little bit Yeah like
um for instance I knew hikar would be
well prepared in the openings and I was
a bit worried about that but fortunately
my one e45 was holding
and uh
I I know hikar very well I knew he would
try to go into this time scrambles so I
had some ideas here and there but uh
it doesn't always work I mean
um obviously I look at the openings and
stuff
um like on some players it's much easier
to go 1d4 than one E4
and uh
yeah it's hard to hard to say exactly
because
like nihal plays all kinds of openings
like it plays eight different openings
so I didn't need to prepare as much
um
yeah sort of like that but you know much
more about match play than me I have
very little over the board match
experience compared to you but you know
I'm hoping one day that will change so
Wesley I wanted to ask like you know
jumping back a little bit from you know
the individual games like this is held
in Toronto I'm from Toronto I know you
have some history in Canada you've
played some events so I mean what are
your impressions about the city of
Toronto and maybe you know will we get
more tournaments in Kansas from Toronto
here so thank you
yeah what do you think of Toronto Wesley
yeah I think Toronto is a great City I
met a few people here they're very very
friendly and very welcoming uh
uh they're just great people I also
heard that it's one of the it's the one
of the safest if not the safest fit in
North America
that's great yeah I I actually played
some tournaments here in Canada 10 years
ago played in Edmonton I played Montreal
played Toronto I also played in Calgary
and uh you know I'm
I'm glad to be back I haven't been to
Canada ever since but uh you know I know
people are very friendly and very
welcoming and uh they accept you for who
you are and some of the fans here
like I know one guy who literally
traveled six hours by train just to get
there met him in the lobby two days ago
and uh you know he was he was very
thrilled and it's nice to see people who
love the game like that because I met
him too sorry yeah Tim I met Tim too
yeah go ahead yeah and uh
I mean compared to
the United States kind of definite as
big of a chair theme but hopefully that
will change it's actually a very
interesting thing for jeff.com to hold
this event here in Toronto yeah and
maybe that's one of the points well
maybe maybe more in the future so all
right well in the future how many more
events will you win but shout out to the
team we've got the bracket to take
another closer look how does this look
to you Wesley to see your name as the
chess.com Global champion and yes
unbelievable yeah yeah also yeah the
fact that I didn't lose any games like
just like a dream come true yeah like uh
yeah if you told me I play like this
I would never believe you and I'm the
deal
well maybe that keeps you in the right
mindset man congratulations you did play
like this you are the first ever
chess.com Global Champion but before you
go every celebration deserves a cake we
also have dania's birthday coming up
tomorrow so right now we are joined by
Alina of Luxe Bakery you can follow her
at Lux Baker on Instagram she made this
incredible cake for us here it's gonna
be super tasty I bet thank you so much
Alina again you can check her out on
Instagram at luxbaker
all right you want a piece well where's
then yeah oh yeah it's his birthday
sorry it's only his birthday I'm
celebrating you first man oh okay
I love you Dania nobody knows how old
Daniel is
all right well before we wrap things up
a final word again from Brave our
sponsor we appreciate their support so
much Brave means private browsing and so
much more by default Brave blocks ads
and trackers on every page and video you
visit even on YouTube no ads means up to
three times faster page loads faster
streaming and faster playback it also
means 35 longer battery life while
saving on mobile data and internet
bandwidth for Android iOS and desktop
get the best browser for gamer streamers
and creative switch in 60 seconds at
brave.com chess
all right well that's almost a wrap for
us in Toronto what an amazing week we
have had a super big thanks to the
scheinberg family and the one Hotel
Toronto for being such amazing hosts
here for Amon Canty Donya Levy Hess Fabi
Nemo our champion Gary as well we want
to show our appreciation for you chat
for watching and being a part of this
all week with such huge numbers thank
you as well to waveform our production
partner who did such an amazing job
bringing this every bringing this all
together on stream and of course a huge
shout out to everyone from Toronto for
being here everyone from the chess.com
team who helped make this happen shout
out to all the players who were in this
event who didn't make it here maybe you
will be at chess.com Global champion in
the future thanks for being with us
everybody so as we make our way out one
last reminder that the SCC is back
that's where we'll be next these players
you see before you are going to be
kicking things off on November 21st
participants include Magnus Arjun Hikaru
Yanda Palm machine Fabiano Wesley so
we'll be there as well they're all going
to try to earn their way for 100k along
with two other qualifiers who haven't
punched their ticket yet you don't want
to miss any of the most exciting speed
Chess Championship to date type SCC in
the chat for more all right everybody
that's officially a wrap for the 2022
chess.com Global Championship presented
by Brave we've had so many amazing
moments this week
I'm Danny wrench I want to give one last
shout out Make Some Noise Toronto we
hear you in the background thank you so
much for hosting this incredible event
and we hope to be back
thank you to everybody thank you to the
team thank you to everyone who's
crushing it and working super hard at
chess.com to all the players one last
time this has been the global
championship this was Toronto and we
will see you next for the speed Chess
Championship
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign